With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver, so you can over-share your preferences. Want russet potatoes with no brown spots? You got it. Want turnips that look light, but feel heavy? Easy. Want honey-crisp apples that are firm, green, and definitely not Macintosh like last year when you lost the fall bake-off to perfect Penelope Johnson? Okay, a bit TMI, but we're here for it.
有了 Instacart，您就能买到超乎预期的杂货，从而更尽情地分享您的偏好。想要没有褐斑的褐皮土豆？没问题。想要看起来轻但拿起来沉的芜菁？简单。想要脆甜、结实、青色，且绝对不是像去年那样让你在秋季烘焙大赛中输给完美佩内洛普·约翰逊（Penelope Johnson）的那种麦金托什苹果？好吧，这有点信息过载了，但我们乐意效劳。
So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Get your shrewbucks ready because today is your second drink of the job part two. Oh, my goodness. Lady, I said last week that I watched this whole episode. And even though we did this whole rewatch of the series, I still forgot that Dwight prematurely paints Michael's office black.
所以今天就下载应用程序，前三单可享 0 美元配送费。Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。服务费、排除条款和条件适用。准备好你的“鼩鼱币”（shrewbucks）吧，因为今天是《工作（下）》的第二杯饮品时间。天哪。女士，我上周说过我看了这一整集。尽管我们已经重温了整个系列，但我还是忘了德怀特（Dwight）提前把迈克尔（Michael）的办公室漆成了黑色。
It made me laugh so hard. I know, I know. I went back and I watched all the deleted scenes for this one too. Mm-hmm. And the amount of paint. I mean, to get it that dark, I just thought about, like, how long that would have taken. Also, Jenna, last week, you talked about how much extra footage was added back to the superfan episode. Yeah, it's like 20 minutes of extra stuff for this two-part episode.
这让我笑得停不下来。我知道，我知道。我也回去看了这一集的删减片段。嗯哼。还有油漆的量。我是说，要把它漆得那么黑，我一直在想，那得花多长时间啊。还有，珍娜（Jenna），上周你谈到了“超级粉丝”版剧集增加了多少额外镜头。是的，这一集两部分的内容增加了大约 20 分钟的额外片段。
I absolutely loved it. Well, I was delighted to see that they added back something we talked about in our breakdown. You know how Michael is being interviewed by David Wallace? Oh, yeah. There is so much more of that that they added. Yes. I mean, these were all in the day. deleted scenes and we talk about them in our breakdown. And I mentioned my favorite was when
我太喜欢了。嗯，我很高兴看到他们加回了我们在解析中谈到的内容。你知道迈克尔接受大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）采访的那段吗？哦，是的。他们加进去了更多那样的内容。是的。我是说，这些都是当天的删减片段，我们在解析中谈到了它们。我提到我最喜欢的是当
David asked Michael the question, where do you see yourself in 10 years? But I didn't play it for you and I just really want you to hear it. Where do you see yourself in 10 years? Well, I've actually done a lot of thinking about that. And in 10 years, I am living in a big house with my kids. and in this house we have screens on the walls that have famous art on them and I have a remote that works everything that has like a belt loop attachment
大卫问迈克尔那个问题：“你十年后在哪里？”但我没给你放，我真的很想让你听听。你十年后在哪里？嗯，我其实对此做了很多思考。十年后，我住在一栋大房子里，和我的孩子们在一起。在这个房子里，我们的墙上有显示著名艺术品的屏幕，我有一个可以控制一切的遥控器，它带有一个皮带扣，
or in my ear like a glue tooth and because it's the future I can take just a little tiny pill and get all my vitamins for the whole day a multivitam? I don't know what to. it's going to be called. But my point is, the future of this company is now. And the future is me. He describes a multivitamin, but also the callback to Bluetooth. Yes, that he says
或者像蓝牙（glue tooth）一样戴在耳朵上，因为这是未来，我可以只吃一颗小药丸就能获得全天所需的所有维生素，一种多种维生素？我不知道它会被叫什么。但我的重点是，这家公司的未来就是现在。而未来就是我。他描述的是多种维生素，但也提到了对蓝牙的呼应。是的，他说
Bluetooth wrong. Well, you know, a lot of times the superfan episodes do add back things that can also be found in the deleted scenes on the DVDs. Absolutely. Like those extended moments between Michael and David Wallace. But sometimes they have moments that are a total surprise that are not in the deleted scenes. And there is one of those in the job part two. When I was rewatching the episode, I was like, oh my God, what the hell? It is a scene with a celebrity cameo that I didn't even remember had happened. So let me break it down for you. It happens at corporate. Jim and Karen are waiting to interview for the job, and this other employee walks in named Print, and he starts chatting up Jim. It's totally out of left field. Print is played by Jeff Garland. I had no idea
蓝牙说错了。嗯，你知道，很多时候“超级粉丝”版剧集确实会加回一些在 DVD 删减片段中也能找到的内容。绝对是这样。就像迈克尔和大卫·华莱士之间那些扩展的时刻。但有时他们会有一些完全出人意料的时刻，这些时刻并不在删减片段里。在《工作（下）》中就有这样一个时刻。当我重温这一集时，我心想，天哪，这到底是什么？这是一个有名人客串的场景，我甚至都不记得发生过。让我为你解析一下。它发生在公司总部。吉姆（Jim）和凯伦（Karen）正在等候面试，然后另一个员工走了进来，名叫普伦特（Print），他开始和吉姆聊天。这完全是意料之外的。普伦特由杰夫·加兰（Jeff Garland）饰演。我根本不知道
that Jeff Garland did a guest appearance on the office. You have to hear it. Hey, Prent. Jimmo! How you doing, man? I'm doing great. How you doing? All right, all right. I haven't seen you since you were at Stanford. How'd the transition go? It was great. It weren't really well. I actually might be working here if I get the job. I heard. I'll put in a good word for you. Thank you. Fantasy football is insane here. Last year, I smashed a lamp
杰夫·加兰在《办公室》里客串过。你一定要听听。嘿，普伦特。吉莫！你好吗，伙计？我很好。你呢？很好，很好。自从你在斯坦福大学之后我就没见过你了。过渡得怎么样？很棒。进行得非常顺利。如果我得到这份工作，我可能真的会在这里工作。我听说了。我会为你美言几句的。谢谢。这里的梦幻足球太疯狂了。去年，我把一盏灯
over a guy's head. Wow. Really? No, I didn't do that. I wouldn't do that. But anyhow, it is intense. It is intense. Winner gets $10,000. No way. No, like $500. And you get like a little crappy trophy. But you're going to have a great interview. I know it. And good luck. Thank you. I think I will have a great interview.
砸在了一个人的头上。哇。真的吗？不，我没那么做。我不会那么做的。但不管怎样，这很激烈。真的很激烈。获胜者能得到 10,000 美元。不会吧。不，大概 500 美元。你会得到一个破烂的小奖杯。但你会有一个很棒的面试的。我知道。祝你好运。谢谢。我想我会有一个很棒的面试的。
I'm going in for it, too. I know you. I do. Really? Did we go to college together? I kind of doubted. I think I'm younger than you. No, it took me like about 11 years to finish, so it's still possible. I, no.
我也要去面试。我知道你。我知道。真的吗？我们一起上过大学吗？我有点怀疑。我想我比你年轻。不，我花了大约 11 年才读完，所以还是有可能的。我，不。
Mr. Philopelling, Mr. Wallace is ready for you. Okay. Good luck. Thanks. Yeah. Listen, um, I really did smash a lamp over a guy's head, but it had nothing to do with fantasy football, but I just thought you should know. No. It's the most random scene. I had to go to the script and look and see, and it is there, sure enough, and they did it totally scripted. None of that was improvised at all.
菲洛佩林先生（Mr. Philopelling），华莱士先生准备好见你了。好的。祝你好运。谢谢。听着，嗯，我确实把一盏灯砸在了一个人的头上，但这和梦幻足球无关，但我只是觉得你应该知道。不。这是最随机的场景。我不得不去查剧本看看，它确实在那里，而且他们完全是照着剧本演的。那一点都不是即兴发挥的。
That's amazing, because it sounds like they go off, you know, script a little bit there. No, this was totally written. And the note in the script said this, quote, a congenial guy from corporate, print, played by a comedian, walks in from the elevators. So this was a totally planned cameo opportunity. Well, this makes sense to me about a photo I saw online because, you know, I always am looking for pictures to post for our Instagram on Wednesdays. And there was a picture of Jeff Garland and John, but they're on the Dundermifflin corporate set. Yeah, that was from this. Oh, my gosh. Crazy cameo. And what an interesting name print. Is it short for something? Oh, exactly. Well, finally, lady, in our breakdown for this episode, did a deep dive on the bar, the limelight in New York. Do you remember this? Yes, of course. It was this old
太神奇了，因为听起来他们好像有点脱离剧本了。不，这完全是写好的。剧本里的备注是这样写的，引用：“一个来自总部的随和家伙，普伦特，由一位喜剧演员饰演，从电梯里走出来。”所以这是一个完全计划好的客串机会。嗯，这让我明白了我在网上看到的一张照片，因为你知道，我总是寻找周三发到 Instagram 上的照片。有一张杰夫·加兰和约翰（John）的照片，但他们是在邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）总部的布景里。是的，那就是从这里来的。天哪。疯狂的客串。还有“普伦特”这个名字真有趣。它是某个名字的缩写吗？哦，确实。好吧，最后，女士，在我们对这一集的解析中，深入探讨了纽约的 Limelight 酒吧。你还记得吗？是的，当然。那是这个古老的
church that was turned into a bar and then a nightclub. Yes. And you said like the nuns quarters were turned into a shampoo room where you get sprayed with foam. Yeah. Okay, well, we got a comment from someone who said, ladies, it's called a champagne room. Oh. Not a shampoo room. And the foam is from the champagne. I went back and listen and lady in this breakdown, you and I, we are convinced that there is a nightclub that has a shampoo room that sprays you with foam. Like in our minds, this made total sense. Of course, yeah, you go in. It's real foamy in there because of the shampoo. I now have more questions because, you know, you see like whatever, your channel surfing and then all of a sudden it's like some travel show and it's like, everybody tonight in Ibiza.
教堂，后来变成了一个酒吧，然后又变成了夜总会。是的。你说修女的宿舍变成了洗发室，在那里你会喷上泡沫。是的。好吧，我们收到了一条评论，有人说：“女士们，那叫香槟房（champagne room）。”哦。不是洗发室（shampoo room）。泡沫是香槟产生的。我回去听了，女士，在这个解析中，你和我，我们确信有一家夜总会有一个会喷泡沫的洗发室。在我们的脑海里，这完全说得通。当然，是的，你进去。里面因为洗发水而变得泡沫飞扬。我现在有更多问题了，因为你知道，你看着，随便什么频道，然后突然间它就像某个旅游节目，就像，“今晚在伊比沙岛的每个人。”
and it's like, it looks like foam. I've seen those too. Isn't that not made of some kind of soap thing? That's champagne? No, but I think this special room, I think it's popular in strip clubs. Like, it's a VIP, like, champagne room, and then you, like, spray champagne. So what is it getting, so probably making it worse. Now, right now, I don't know.
看起来就像泡沫。我也见过那些。那不是用某种肥皂做的吗？那是香槟？不，但我认为这个特殊的房间，我认为它在脱衣舞俱乐部很流行。就像，这是一个贵宾室，像“香槟房”，然后你，就像，喷香槟。所以它到底是什么，可能让情况变得更糟了。现在，我不知道。
What is a foam party then? Oh, no, lady. I don't know what a phone party is. I barely know if what I'm saying is true right now. Well, I think I want to Google foam. Yes. It's a social event where guests dance and play in a space filled with fluffy, soapy foam. Thank you.
那什么是泡沫派对呢？哦，不，女士。我不知道什么是泡沫派对。我现在几乎不知道我说的对不对。好吧，我想我想去谷歌搜一下泡沫。是的。这是一个社交活动，客人在充满蓬松、肥皂泡沫的空间里跳舞和玩耍。谢谢。
Created by a foam machine. I think that's what I thought a shampoo room was. Yeah. Okay. Well, guys. If you Google shampoo room, you just get pictures of salons. Okay. There's no class.
由泡沫机制造。我想这就是我以为洗发室是什么的样子。是的。好吧，伙计们。如果你谷歌搜索“洗发室”，你只会得到沙龙的照片。好吧。没有档次。
Look. Sorry. We are not your go-to for nightclub information. Clearly. All right, everyone. Well, that's all we got. But before we break down the job part two, I wanted to give a shout out to Craig Thomas. You know Craig and Josh Radner are now on the Office Ladies Network.
看。抱歉。我们不是你寻找夜总会信息的首选。显然。好了，各位。这就是我们所有的内容了。但在我们解析《工作（下）》之前，我想向克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）致敬。你知道克雷格和乔什·拉德诺（Josh Radner）现在在“办公室女士网络”（Office Ladies Network）了吗？
Their podcast, How We Made Your Mother, is one of our new shows. And Craig has written such a great book. It's called That's Not How It Happened. Here's a little blurb about it. It is a smart, funny, big-hearted novel that follows a family turned upside down after Hollywood decides to make a movie version of their lives. And it has an audiobook narrated by Kobe Smolders and Josh Radner. It's available November 4th. And you can pre-order now. I'll put a swipe up in our stories. And you know, a lot of the relationships in this book are loosely based on Craig's life.
他们的播客《我们是如何制作老爸老妈浪漫史的》（How We Made Your Mother）是我们新节目之一。克雷格写了一本很棒的书。书名叫《那不是事情发生的经过》（That's Not How It Happened）。这里有一段关于它的简介。这是一部聪明、有趣、充满温情的小说，讲述了一个家庭在好莱坞决定将他们的生活拍成电影后，生活被彻底颠覆的故事。它有一本由寇碧·史莫德斯（Cobie Smulders）和乔什·拉德诺朗读的有声书。11 月 4 日上市。你现在可以预订了。我会把链接放在我们的故事里。而且你知道，书中的许多关系都松散地基于克雷格的生活。
And he is such a wonderful guy. Let me just read a little quote by Lynn Manuel Miranda, who said it is funny, real, and moving all at once. A wonderful, heartfelt debut. So Craig, we wish you all the best, and you guys, I'll put all this info in our stories. And now, let's break down the job part two. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello and welcome back to office ladies.
他是一个非常棒的人。让我读一下林-曼努埃尔·米兰达（Lin-Manuel Miranda）的一句引语，他说：“它既有趣、真实，又感人。一部精彩、真诚的处女作。”所以克雷格，我们祝你一切顺利，伙计们，我会把所有这些信息放在我们的故事里。现在，让我们来解析《工作（下）》。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好，欢迎回到办公室女士。
This week we are breaking down the job part two. It's the season three finale second half written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Schor, directed by Ken Kwapis. Last week, we interviewed Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, about this episode. It was great. So fun. So fun to talk to him. Well, this week we're going to break down the second half. And I've got a summary to catch us up.
本周我们正在解析《工作（下）》。这是第三季大结局的后半部分，由保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）和迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）编剧，肯·卡皮斯（Ken Kwapis）执导。上周，我们采访了保罗·利伯斯坦，也就是托比（Toby），谈论了这一集。太棒了。很有趣。和他聊天太有趣了。好吧，本周我们将解析后半部分。我有一个总结来帮我们回顾一下。
Well, Jenna, you know I can't wait to hear it, so. I know. Now, do you really like my summaries, Angela, or is this, are you patronizing me? I actually really do. Now, that probably sounded like I was being some BFF SaaS to you, but I actually really do because you're so good at summarizing them. I think you might have missed your calling as like someone who writes the caption for movies, you know, like. Oh, yeah. The thing that comes up on your TV guide?
嗯，珍娜，你知道我迫不及待想听了，所以。我知道。现在，你真的喜欢我的总结吗，安吉拉，还是说，你在屈尊俯就我？我其实真的很喜欢。现在，那听起来可能像是我在对你表现出闺蜜式的讽刺，但我其实真的很喜欢，因为你非常擅长总结它们。我想你可能错过了作为电影字幕撰写人的职业，你知道，就像。哦，是的。出现在电视指南上的那个东西？
Yes. Yes. I think you could have been that person. except for look who's talking. That made me laugh out loud. I know, I got you. Okay, so give us a summary. All right.
是的。是的。我觉得你本可以成为那个人。除了看看是谁在说话。那让我大笑出声。我知道，我抓到你了。好吧，给我们一个总结。好的。
Last week, we discussed how Michael got back together with Jan after she revealed her breast enhancement. He named Dwight as his successor to Dunder Mifflin because he was so sure he was going to get this job at corporate. But I have just pause one second. here, is that even Michael's decision to make? We did not talk about this. I mean, if Michael gets the job at corporate, is he allowed to just say who gets the manager job at Dunder Mifflin Scranton? No. No. Right? Absolutely not. I'm sure that's like a corporate decision
上周，我们讨论了迈克尔在简（Jan）透露了她的隆胸手术后是如何与她复合的。他任命德怀特为他在邓德·米夫林的继任者，因为他非常确定自己会得到总部的这份工作。但我必须暂停一下。这里，这甚至是迈克尔能决定的吗？我们没有讨论过这个。我是说，如果迈克尔得到了总部的职位，他能就这样说谁得到邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿分部的经理职位吗？不。不。对吧？绝对不行。我敢肯定那是一个公司决策，
where they like have an overview of all, and you know, all the employees. I'm sure Michael gets to put in his recommendation as someone that worked in that branch, but ultimately that would be David Wallace's decision. Thank you. I feel like we failed to discuss that last week and I needed to bring it up. Well, I got you. Done and done. All right.
他们会对所有员工进行全面评估。我敢肯定迈克尔可以作为在该分部工作过的人提出他的建议，但最终那将是大卫·华莱士的决定。谢谢。我觉得我们上周没讨论那个，我需要提出来。好吧，我抓到你了。搞定。好的。
So also last week, Dwight interviewed Andy to be as number two and Jim and Karen left for New York. This week, Pam is going to become Dwight's secret assistant to the regional manager. We will see Michael, Jim, and Karen all interview for the position at corporate and we will ultimately find out who gets the job. Yes. There's some relationship stuff thrown in there, too, but, you know, there's a little bit. Isn't there of relationship stuff? All right, fast fact number one, fan question from Maddie Jensen. I noticed that Ken Kwapis directed the finale for season three, along with the finale of season two. Both episodes are crucial to the Jim Pam plotline of the show. Was this an intentional decision to have the same director in charge of these important episodes? Or was it
所以上周，德怀特面试了安迪（Andy）作为他的二把手，吉姆和凯伦去了纽约。本周，帕姆（Pam）将成为德怀特的“地区经理助理的秘密助理”。我们将看到迈克尔、吉姆和凯伦都去面试总部的职位，我们最终会发现谁得到了这份工作。是的。里面还掺杂了一些关系方面的内容，但是，你知道，有一点。不是有关系方面的内容吗？好的，第一个快速事实，来自麦迪·詹森（Maddie Jensen）的粉丝提问。我注意到肯·卡皮斯执导了第三季的大结局，以及第二季的大结局。这两集对剧中吉姆和帕姆的情节线至关重要。让同一位导演负责这些重要剧集是一个有意的决定吗？还是
just a happy accident? Well, this was very intentional. I'm so glad you said that because I was sitting here and I wasn't sure. I was like, what is she going to say? And I was like, I hope it was thought out because Ken was so caring about the different dynamics and relationships on the show. He had been with us since the pilot. We had such a trust for his vision. And if you were about to say, it was just a scheduling thing. I was going to be like, no. No, I traded some emails with Kent Zabornak, and he told me that he and Greg always wanted Ken Kwapis to direct milestone episodes. So season openers, season closers, or any episodes with big story movement, especially if they involved Jim and Pam. He wasn't always available,
只是一个快乐的巧合？嗯，这是非常有意的。我很高兴你这么说，因为我坐在这里，我不确定。我在想，她会说什么？我心想，我希望这是经过深思熟虑的，因为肯非常关心剧中不同的动态和关系。他从试播集开始就和我们在一起了。我们对他的愿景有着极大的信任。如果你刚才要说，这只是一个排程问题。我会说，不。不。我和肯特·扎博纳克（Kent Zbornak）交换了一些邮件，他告诉我，他和格雷格（Greg）一直希望肯·卡皮斯执导里程碑式的剧集。所以季首、季终，或者任何有重大故事发展的剧集，特别是如果它们涉及吉姆和帕姆。他并不总是能抽出时间，
but that was the intention. And if you look back, Ang, you'll see that oftentimes it was Ken Quapis, Greg Daniels, Paul Fieg, or Paul Lieberstein, who would direct these big milestone episodes, which makes sense because those guys were kind of the original team of visionaries for the show, and they were with us since the first season. Yeah, so they knew every character's journey, and I think that was super important. That was sometimes a learning curve for new directors. If they hadn't seen every single episode, they would come in and maybe not understand why a character was making a certain choice. And I remember the cast would sometimes
但这就是初衷。如果你回顾一下，安吉，你会发现通常是肯·卡皮斯、格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）、保罗·费格（Paul Feig）或保罗·利伯斯坦来执导这些重大的里程碑剧集，这很有道理，因为这些人算是该剧最初的愿景团队，而且他们从第一季就和我们在一起了。是的，所以他们了解每个角色的旅程，我认为这非常重要。这对新导演来说有时是一个学习曲线。如果他们没有看过每一集，他们进来时可能不明白为什么一个角色会做出某种选择。我记得演员们有时会
just bring them up to speed. Oh, I did. I remember I was in a scene. I forget who the director was, but they were like, so let's have Angela over there, like cutting the meat or something. It was like a party episode. And I was like, oh, she wouldn't touch that meat. She's a vegetarian. She wouldn't go near it. Yes. And they're like, oh, okay, I guess I'll put you over there by the bag of chips. I'm like, yes, that's better. Exactly. So this created a really nice sense of consistency for those big episodes to bring people back who knew us all so well. All right, fast fact number two, this is a fan question from Beatrix Smith, Brooke B, Amelia C, Erica P, and Suba Nanduri.
只是让他们跟上进度。哦，我记得。我记得我当时在一个场景里，我忘了导演是谁，但他们说：“那么，让安吉拉在那边，切肉什么的。”那是一集派对剧集。我说：“哦，她不会碰那块肉的。她是素食主义者。她不会靠近它的。”是的。他们说：“哦，好吧，我想我会把你放在薯片袋旁边。”我说：“是的，那样更好。”完全正确。所以这为那些大剧集创造了一种非常好的连贯感，让那些非常了解我们的人回来。好的，第二个快速事实，这是一个来自比阿特丽克斯·史密斯（Beatrix Smith）、布鲁克·B（Brooke B）、阿米莉亚·C（Amelia C）、埃里卡·P（Erica P）和苏巴·南杜里（Suba Nanduri）的粉丝提问。
Did the conversation at the beach between Jim and Pam that we see throughout this episode, did it have to be recreated like The Kiss on Casino Night? or was it a deleted scene that was added later without audio? What's the story? Well, guys, this was a new scene, but we knew about it when we were shooting beach games. So we shot this during the beach games shoot. We did not have to go back to the dam. Oh yeah, we couldn't get that location again. So they shot it while we were there. And Jenna, I remember that they brought Ken Quapis to direct that. So, and that was actually very common. That wasn't like anything weird to Harold Ramos. That was really common on a show. If you had a crossboard moment where you had a scene that was in another episode, the director of that episode would come and direct that to sort of complete their story. So Ken came back and Jenna, I read that this was supposed to be in the beginning of the show, like the cold open. Yes, just like that jump from casino night to gay witch hunt.
吉姆和帕姆在海滩上的对话，我们在这一集中看到的，它必须像《赌场之夜》里的吻戏那样重新拍摄吗？还是它是一个后来在没有音频的情况下添加的删减片段？故事是什么？嗯，伙计们，这是一个新场景，但我们在拍摄《海滩游戏》时就知道它了。所以我们在拍摄《海滩游戏》时拍了它。我们不必回到那个大坝。哦，是的，我们无法再次获得那个地点。所以他们在我们在那里的时候拍了它。而且珍娜，我记得他们带了肯·卡皮斯来执导那个。所以，这实际上非常普遍。那对哈罗德·雷米斯（Harold Ramis）来说没什么奇怪的。这在剧组里真的很普遍。如果你有一个跨剧集的时刻，有一个在另一集里的场景，那一集的导演会过来执导那个，以某种方式完成他们的故事。所以肯回来了，珍娜，我读到这本应该在剧集的开头，就像冷开场。是的，就像从《赌场之夜》到《同性恋搜捕》的跳跃。
We were going to originally open this episode. The cold open was going to be watching this scene between Jim and Pam on the beach. I'm so glad it wasn't that way. I think it creates so much more tension. Yeah. To leave it until later as a flashback. And, you know, Jenna, it really did add to the tension because now we know as the audience that they had had this moment. And so when Pam is saying goodbye and good luck.
我们原本打算在这一集的开头。冷开场本来是观看吉姆和帕姆在海滩上的这个场景。我很高兴它不是那样。我认为它创造了更多的张力。是的。把它留到后面作为闪回。而且，你知道，珍娜，它确实增加了张力，因为现在作为观众，我们知道他们有过这个时刻。所以当帕姆说再见和祝你好运时，
and all of that, it's layered with this moment that they shared at beach games. And I love that our show did this. Our show didn't always just spoon feed the audience. It just had them like sort of pick up in the middle. And I, and I just loved it. Me too. Me too. It was during the editing process that they decided to take it out of the cold open and put it later. Dave Rogers said in the DVD commentary that it was Mike Scher's idea to make it a flashback later in the episode. I love that. I know. He's so smart.
以及所有这些，它与他们在《海滩游戏》中分享的这一刻交织在一起。我喜欢我们的剧集这样做。我们的剧集并不总是只是喂给观众。它只是让他们像是在中间接上。我，我只是喜欢它。我也是。我也是。是在剪辑过程中，他们决定把它从冷开场中拿出来，放在后面。戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）在 DVD 评论中说，这是迈克·舒尔的主意，把它作为剧集后面的闪回。我喜欢那个。我知道。他太聪明了。
He's such a smotty. Fast fact number three, Angela, I'm staying consistent today. It is a fan question from Fay B. Kayla Moffat, Tiffany L. Brianna Kay and Rowena C. Did John and Rashida actually film in New York and how much of the crew was with them? Yeah, guys. Yeah.
他真是个聪明鬼。第三个快速事实，安吉拉，我今天保持一致。这是一个来自费伊·B（Fay B）、凯拉·莫法特（Kayla Moffat）、蒂芙尼·L（Tiffany L）、布里安娜·K（Brianna K）和罗威娜·C（Rowena C）的粉丝提问。约翰和拉什达（Rashida）真的在纽约拍摄了吗？有多少剧组人员和他们在一起？是的，伙计们。是的。
They went to New York for one day of filming. We were so envious. Whenever anyone got to go anywhere, because we never got to go on big trips, but this was a skeleton crew, and they went to New York. Yeah, we actually wrapped filming in Los Angeles on March 28, 2007. They did not go to New York to pick up the Jim and Karen scenes until April 19th of 2007. So we had been wrapped for the season for a little while. Wow, I didn't know that. That was from Kentapedia.
他们去纽约拍摄了一天。我们太羡慕了。每当有人能去任何地方时，因为我们从来没有去过大旅行，但这只是一个精简的剧组，他们去了纽约。是的，我们实际上在 2007 年 3 月 28 日结束了在洛杉矶的拍摄。他们直到 2007 年 4 月 19 日才去纽约拍摄吉姆和凯伦的场景。所以我们已经结束了那一季的拍摄有一段时间了。哇，我不知道。那是来自“肯特百科”（Kentapedia）。
Of course he's going to give us those details. He's Kentapedia. Well, the people who went were Greg Paul, Mike Scher, Kent, Randall, our DP, our camera assistant, Chris Workman, and our sound mixer Ben. Now, they talked about this a little bit on the DVD commentary about how they had to sort of do that guerrilla shooting, you know, like they were sort of sneaking around, filming in little spots where they could. and John jokingly called Greg covert Greg Because like Greg would have a note But he wouldn't want to talk directly to him So he'd be like like he would act like he was passing by
当然他会给我们那些细节。他是肯特百科。好吧，去的人是格雷格、保罗、迈克·舒尔、肯特、兰德尔（Randall），我们的摄影指导，我们的摄影助理克里斯·沃克曼（Chris Workman），以及我们的混音师本（Ben）。现在，他们在 DVD 评论中谈到了一点，关于他们如何不得不进行那种游击式拍摄，你知道，就像他们是在偷偷摸摸，在他们能拍的小地方拍摄。约翰开玩笑地称格雷格为“秘密格雷格”（Covert Greg），因为格雷格会有一个备注，但他不想直接和他说话，所以他会像，就像他假装路过
Or he would send Kint Sabornak with his kid Kitt's kid was with him And they would walk across the street And nonchalantly kind of tell John a note And then so it looked like there were just people Pedestrians in Manhattan Amazing Because I guess they didn't want people to notice
或者他会派肯特·扎博纳克带着他的孩子，肯特的儿子和他在一起。他们会穿过马路，漫不经心地告诉约翰一个备注，然后看起来就像他们只是曼哈顿的行人。太神奇了，因为我想他们不想让人们注意到
that they were filming because all those people became background people. They didn't want to draw attention to John and Rashida, I guess. They had seen what happened when people, like, realized Steve was being filmed, right? Yeah. Well, they had a tight day. Kent told me they filmed in nine different locations around New York City, all in that one day, and they hired a local crew to fill out the production for hair, makeup, wardrobe grips, electric drivers, craft service, and set production assistant.
他们在拍摄，因为所有那些人变成了背景人物。我想他们不想引起对约翰和拉什达的注意。他们见过当人们意识到史蒂夫（Steve）在被拍摄时发生了什么，对吧？是的。好吧，他们那天很忙。肯特告诉我，他们在那一天里在纽约市的九个不同地点拍摄，他们雇佣了一个当地剧组来填补发型、化妆、服装、场务、电工、司机、餐饮和现场制片助理的制作。
they had to come up with a little mini New York crew, but that's how we did it. I love it. I love it. Here's one other little piece of trivia. Rashida and John said that they wore their own clothes for all the scenes in New York City. That makes sense to me. Yeah. I also thought they looked really cute. And I was like, oh, like, Rashida has great taste. And John is cute. They look like, they look like normal people, not like, you know, the Dundermifflin folks. Here's some tidbits. Ready? Okay, Kinsey Tidbits. Kinsey Tidpit from the DVD commentary, John said that there was like this kind of drunk guy while they were filming in the restaurant. And he kept coming up to them. And he's in a white shirt.
他们不得不凑出一个小型的纽约剧组，但这就是我们做到的方式。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。这里还有一点小花絮。准备好了吗？好的，金赛小花絮。来自 DVD 评论的金赛小花絮，约翰说当他们在餐厅拍摄时，有一个醉汉。他一直走过来找他们。他穿着一件白衬衫。
So if you see it, 1934, there's a guy standing there sort of next to John. And he was like, where are you guys doing? And John sort of was like trying to keep it like, you know, he didn't want to draw attention to it because they were filming from like across the street, you know? Yeah, through the window. Yeah. So he was like, oh, you know, man, we're just doing a scene. He's like, oh, you're doing a scene. You're doing a scene. He was like, buddy, come on. So they were, and he said that he like, this guy like heckled them through that whole moment. That is crazy. I know. Listen, lady, should we take a quick break? And then when we come back, we can start breaking down the job, part two.
所以如果你看到它，1934 年，有一个人站在那里，就在约翰旁边。他就像，“你们在做什么？”约翰有点像试图保持，你知道，他不想引起注意，因为他们是从街对面拍摄的，你知道？是的，透过窗户。是的。所以他说，“哦，你知道，伙计，我们只是在拍一个场景。”他说，“哦，你在拍一个场景。你在拍一个场景。”他说，“伙计，拜托。”所以他们，他说他就像，这个家伙在整个过程中一直嘲讽他们。太疯狂了。我知道。听着，女士，我们要不要休息一下？然后当我们回来时，我们可以开始解析《工作（下）》。
Yeah, let's do it. All right. We'll be right back. Hi, I'm Dr. Mary Claire Haver, a board certified OBGYN and menopause specialist. My new podcast, Unpaused, is the place for bold, unfiltered conversations about what it really takes for women to thrive in the second half of life. Every week, I sit down with medical experts, cultural icons, and powerhouse women to talk about what really matters, your health, your power, and your future. We're covering hormones, identity, finances, relationships, and so much more. New episodes drop every Tuesday.
是的，我们开始吧。好的。我们马上回来。嗨，我是玛丽·克莱尔·哈弗（Dr. Mary Claire Haver）医生，一位委员会认证的妇产科医生和更年期专家。我的新播客《暂停》（Unpaused），是进行大胆、未经修饰的对话的地方，讨论女性在人生下半场真正需要什么才能茁壮成长。每周，我都会与医学专家、文化偶像和强力女性坐下来，谈论真正重要的事情：你的健康、你的力量和你的未来。我们涵盖荷尔蒙、身份、财务、关系等等。新剧集每周二发布。
Listen to and follow unpaused with me, Dr. Mary Claire Haver, available now wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back and Jim and Karen are arriving in New York. They're getting off the subway. And oh my God, Angela. What? Do you have a story about Aster Place? I do not. I want to know, did you see the lady with the big?
收听并关注《暂停》，和我一起，玛丽·克莱尔·哈弗医生，现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。好的，我们回来了，吉姆和凯伦到达了纽约。他们正在下地铁。天哪，安吉拉。什么？你关于阿斯特广场（Aster Place）有什么故事吗？我没有。我想知道，你看到那个带着大婴儿车的女士了吗？
baby stroller who gives major side eye to John and Rashida? No, is she by, as they come out of the subway station? As they come out of the subway station, there is a woman with a baby stroller. She is clearly not with us. She's just a lady walking her kid. Living her life. Live in her life. It's at 18 minutes, 29 seconds.
她给了约翰和拉什达一个巨大的白眼？不，她在他们走出地铁站的地方吗？当他们走出地铁站时，有一个带着婴儿车的女人。她显然不是和我们一起的。她只是一个带着孩子散步的女士。过着她的生活。过着她的生活。是在 18 分 29 秒。
I need to know who this woman is. I need to hear her story. I need to see her face. I need to see it. I took a picture. Oh, good. Show me. Show me.
我需要知道这个女人是谁。我需要听听她的故事。我需要看到她的脸。我需要看到它。我拍了一张照片。哦，好。给我看。给我看。
We'll put it in our Insta Stories, guys. Office Ladies' Pod. Office Ladies' Pod. Okay, lady, I found it. Here she is. She's so annoyed. I love her. She's so over it.
我们会把它放在我们的 Instagram 故事里，伙计们。Office Ladies' Pod。Office Ladies' Pod。好的，女士，我找到了。她就在这里。她太烦了。我爱她。她太受不了了。
She is so over it. Oh, my gosh. So over it. We, Lady with Stroller. Please contact us at Office Ladies' Pod. Lady with Stroller. Sorry. Yes, please email us at OfficeLadies at Earwolf.com.
她太受不了了。天哪。太受不了了。我们，带婴儿车的女士。请通过 Office Ladies' Pod 联系我们。带婴儿车的女士。抱歉。是的，请发邮件给我们 OfficeLadies@Earwolf.com。
What is she going to say? I just, she's like prominently featured in an episode of the office. Is she an office fan? What does she remember about that day? Did she recognize them? Because her response is like, who are these guys? Well, Jenna, she wasn't the only one who was ticked off that day because at 20 minutes, 34 seconds, there is a girl and clearly like a party dress and she's hailing a cab. She was not an extra.
她会说什么？我只是，她就像在《办公室》的一集中被重点展示。她是《办公室》的粉丝吗？她对那天有什么记忆？她认出他们了吗？因为她的反应就像，“这些人是谁？”嗯，珍娜，那天被惹恼的不止她一个，因为在 20 分 34 秒，有一个女孩，显然穿着派对礼服，她在拦出租车。她不是临时演员。
and I guess they had to make her stop hailing her cab because she was so featured and sign a release and she was really annoyed because she like missed her cab or something. They talk about it on the DVD commentary. She was like, I just, you know, I'm sure she's like, I just want to go to my party. What are these forms?
我想他们不得不让她停止拦出租车，因为她太显眼了，并让她签了一份免责声明，她真的很生气，因为她错过了她的出租车什么的。他们在 DVD 评论中谈到了这一点。她就像，“我只是，你知道，我敢肯定她就像，我只是想去参加我的派对。这些表格是什么？”
Maybe she's like me, Jenna. She doesn't like a lot of forms. Okay, woman with baby stroller, woman hailing a cab, email us. And party dress. In a party dress, we want to hear from you. Okay. before we move on I have a little mini deep dive please okay so Jenna at 1943 Jim mentions that he went to a bar that used to be a church and I was like I know exactly what they're talking about what the limelight remember I don't know the lime no I don't know this place it's on 6th Avenue okay so when I was interning on Conan O'Brien you guys I was you know I was a bit of a sad sack I never went out New York was so expensive I didn't
也许她像我一样，珍娜。她不喜欢太多的表格。好的，带婴儿车的女人，拦出租车的女人，给我们发邮件。还有派对礼服。穿着派对礼服的，我们想听听你的声音。好的。在我们继续之前，我有一个小小的深度解析，请。好的，珍娜，在 19 分 43 秒，吉姆提到他去了一个曾经是教堂的酒吧，我心想，我知道他们说的是什么，Limelight，记得吗？我不知道 Limelight，不，我不知道这个地方，它在第六大道。好的，所以当我在柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）那里实习时，伙计们，我是一个有点悲伤的人，我从不出去，纽约太贵了，我不
didn't know anyone. And a gal I worked with, Debbie Wonder, kind of took me under her wing. And she was like, Angela, you got to get out. I was like, wah. And she said, there's a great band. We're going to go listen to tonight. Jen, I'm pretty sure I wore my gap denim dress and some kids because I knew what New York fashion looks like. Oh, yeah. We show up. By the way, I went with Debbie and her boyfriend, so high, third wheel. We show up to where the band is playing. And it is inside a gothic cathedral that is a bar. And Debbie's like, this is a famous New York bar. And Debbie's like, this is a famous New York bar. And I'm like, um, lady, that's a church. I can't go inside it because I'll get in trouble with my mom. You can't have a bar in a church. Yes, you can. And this church has the most
不认识任何人。我和一个一起工作的女孩，黛比·旺德（Debbie Wonder），她有点照顾我。她说，“安吉拉，你得出去。”我说，“哇。”她说，“有一个很棒的乐队。我们今晚要去听。”珍娜，我很确定我穿了我的 Gap 牛仔裙和一些凉鞋，因为我知道纽约时尚看起来是什么样的。哦，是的。我们出现了。顺便说一句，我和黛比还有她的男朋友一起去的，所以，天哪，电灯泡。我们出现在乐队演奏的地方。它在一个哥特式大教堂里，那是一个酒吧。黛比说，“这是一个著名的纽约酒吧。”黛比说，“这是一个著名的纽约酒吧。”我说，“嗯，女士，那是一个教堂。我不能进去，因为我会惹我妈妈生气。你不能在教堂里开酒吧。”是的，你可以。而且这个教堂有最
cool, amazing story. Okay? I'm going to walk you through it really quickly. So it was built in 1844. It was this Gothic revival church, huge, beautiful structure. It looked like a medieval church, like from England, you know? And it has the main big church, right? I'm talking cathedral ceilings, the big stained glass. Oh, yeah. It's got a rectory. It's got a sister's house for the nuns. It's got a parish house, a chapel, and a garden courtyard. This is huge. Wait. Wait. Is this the one on 6th Avenue with the red door? Yes. Yes. I do know what you're talking about. Okay. It's beautiful, right? It's beautiful. Okay. So I guess, you know, it was a very happening church for a long time. But then in the 60s, the neighborhood kind of took a turn. People started moving out to the suburbs. All of a
酷、令人惊叹的故事。好吗？我会很快带你了解一下。所以它建于 1844 年。这是一个哥特复兴式教堂，巨大、美丽的结构。它看起来像一个中世纪的教堂，就像来自英国，你知道吗？它有主大教堂，对吧？我说的是大教堂天花板，巨大的彩色玻璃。哦，是的。它有一个牧师住宅。它有一个修女的姐妹屋。它有一个教区长屋、一个礼拜堂和一个花园庭院。这太大了。等等。等等。这是第六大道上那个有红门的吗？是的。是的。我知道你在说什么。好的。它很美，对吧？它很美。好的。所以我想，你知道，它很长一段时间里是一个非常热闹的教堂。但后来在 60 年代，社区发生了一些变化。人们开始搬到郊区。突然间，
sudden, this big Gothic structure, you know, it was hard to maintain the heating and the repairs and all of that. So they had to sort of repurpose it. At first, they made it into a cultural center and that sort of went on for a bit. That makes sense, right? Cultural Center. Yep. They couldn't keep up with the cost of running the place. So this famous sort of New York like bar owner bought it and people were furious. They were like, you cannot. make this church a bar. You can't. Well, he did. And he, like, tricked it all out. Like, he made the sister's house, I guess, into, like, the shampoo room, you know, like, where you could... Shampoo room. I didn't know what it was, either. But I guess that's like a party where you get sprayed with foam.
这个巨大的哥特式结构，你知道，很难维持供暖和维修等等。所以他们不得不以某种方式重新利用它。起初，他们把它变成了一个文化中心，那持续了一段时间。这说得通，对吧？文化中心。是的。他们无法跟上运营这个地方的成本。所以这个著名的纽约酒吧老板买下了它，人们非常愤怒。他们说，“你不能把这个教堂变成酒吧。你不能。”好吧，他做了。而且他，就像，把它装饰得很好。就像，他把姐妹屋，我想，变成了洗发室，你知道，就像，在那里你可以……洗发室。我也不知道那是什么。但我猜那是一个你会喷上泡沫的派对。
I don't know. It sounds horrible. I know I would get it in my eyes. How can you not? But he made it this big, big, like, hipster bar scene. Andy Warhol opened it. It. A lot. He said, up on the opening weekend. It was like this big place for music and events from the 80s through the 90s. Then in the 90s, I guess things took a turn. I think crime got bad again. And lady, this party promoter named Michael Alec murdered and dismembered this guy at the limelight. Yeah. He murdered a guy. And so then they were like, okay, they close it down. Then they try to like give it a new reopening. They call it the Avalon in 2003. That's a... doesn't really work. People are like done. They're like, you know, get your bar out of the church.
我不知道。听起来很可怕。我知道我会弄进眼睛里。你怎么能不呢？但他把它变成了这个非常、非常大的，像嬉皮士酒吧场景。安迪·沃霍尔（Andy Warhol）开了它。它。很多。他说，在开业周末。它就像 80 年代到 90 年代音乐和活动的巨大场所。然后在 90 年代，我想事情发生了变化。我想犯罪又变严重了。而且女士，这个叫迈克尔·阿莱克（Michael Alec）的派对发起人在 Limelight 谋杀并肢解了一个人。是的。他谋杀了一个人。所以他们就像，好吧，他们关闭了它。然后他们试图给它一个新的重新开业。他们在 2003 年称它为 Avalon。那是一个……不太奏效。人们就像完了。他们就像，你知道，把你的酒吧从教堂里拿出来。
We're done. 2007, it permanently closed its doors, which is interesting to me because we filmed this in 2007. Wow. Them mentioning that they went to this bar, if we had filmed the following year, they couldn't have done it. Yeah, I think the writers all knew about this bar, right? It was famous, a bar inside of a Gothic church, right? All the writers. knew about it, I think. But here's the interesting thing. Guess what it is today? Not a bar? You're not going to be able to guess. What is it? Well, first of all, the people that bought it restored all of it. It really meant a lot to them to restore the integrity of the structure, the stained glass, but it is partly a gym called the Complete Body Limelight, so you can lift weights
我们完了。2007 年，它永久关闭了大门，这对我来说很有趣，因为我们在 2007 年拍摄了这一集。哇。他们提到他们去了这个酒吧，如果我们是在第二年拍摄的，他们就不能那样做了。是的，我想编剧们都知道这个酒吧，对吧？它很有名，一个在哥特式教堂里的酒吧，对吧？所有的编剧。都知道它，我想。但这里有趣的事情是。猜猜它今天是什么？不是酒吧？你猜不到。它是什么？好吧，首先，买下它的人修复了所有东西。这对他们来说意义重大，要恢复结构的完整性，彩色玻璃，但它部分是一个叫“Complete Body Limelight”的健身房，所以你可以举重
inside the church. And then the chapel is a modern dim sum reference. And then the chapel is a modern dim sum restaurant called Julan Club. So you can go work out and then get some dim sum. Let's do it. Let's do it. I love that. I just found it fascinating because as soon as he said that, Jenna, what do I ever know about any bars or pop culture stuff? Never. Never. Never. You know nothing about them. And not only did I know, but I had been there. That's pretty badass. I know. I went with Debbie and her boyfriend at the time who was a exterminator. Oh. Yeah. And Debbie, it's okay if I say this right. In the cab ride home, you and him started making
在教堂里。然后礼拜堂是一个现代点心参考。然后礼拜堂是一个现代点心餐厅，叫 Julan Club。所以你可以去锻炼，然后吃点点心。我们去做吧。我们去做吧。我喜欢那个。我只是觉得它很迷人，因为他一说那个，珍娜，我什么时候知道任何酒吧或流行文化的东西？从来没有。从来没有。从来没有。你对它们一无所知。而且我不仅知道，我还去过那里。那真是太酷了。我知道。我和黛比还有她当时的男朋友一起去的，他是一个灭虫员。哦。是的。而且黛比，如果我这么说没关系的话。在回家的出租车上，你和他开始亲热，我不得不尴尬地坐在那里看着窗外。听起来他们玩得很开心。他们玩得很开心。妈妈，对不起。我去了一个在教堂里的酒吧，妈妈。对不起。好吧，听着，而且在这次谈话中，吉姆说他们认为他们看到了洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）。我们收到了很多关于那个的粉丝提问，来自安吉拉·A、艾莉·S、克里斯汀·O、泰勒·N、希瑟·C 等等，所有人都想知道，那个走在吉姆后面的人是洛恩·迈克尔斯吗？那是一个小客串笑话吗？不，那不是洛恩·迈克尔斯。
out, and I had to sit awkwardly looking out the window. That sounds like they had a good time. They had a great time. Mom, I'm sorry. I went to a bar that was inside a church, mom. I'm sorry. Well, listen, and also during this talking head, Jim says that they think they saw Lorne Michaels. And we got a lot of fan questions about that from Angela A, Allie S, Kirsten O, Tyler N, Heather C, and many more all want to know is the man that walks behind Jim, Lauren Michaels. Was that a little cameo joke? No, it's not Lauren Michaels.
我放大了。那绝对、绝对不是洛恩·迈克尔斯。我喜欢认为吉姆是一个认为自己认出名人的人，但他们只是普通人。我觉得我姐姐蒂娜（Tina）会那样做。她会说，“那是安吉丽娜·朱莉（Angelina Jolie）。”我说，“安吉丽娜·朱莉现在为什么会在我们家乡的商场里？”是的，完全正确。好吧，你知道，这里发生的另一件事是凯伦有点和吉姆对质。
I zoomed in. It's definitely, definitely not Lorne Michaels. I like to think that Jim is someone who thinks he recognizes famous people places, but they're just just normal folks. I feel like my sister Tina does that. She'd be like, that's Angelina Jolie. I'm like, why would Angelina Jolie be in the mall in our hometown right now? Yes, exactly. Well, you know, another thing that happens here is that Karen kind of confronts Jim.
是的。她说，“如果我们中的一个人得到这份工作，我们的关系会怎样？”如果我得到这份工作，你会搬到纽约和我在一起吗？吉姆显然很不舒服。他在开玩笑。他试图开玩笑。是的。但凯伦把它带了回来，她说，“其实，我是认真的。就像在海滩上发生的事情之后，我和你有未来吗？因为我觉得我在斯克兰顿没有未来，但我很想和你有一个未来。”好吧，她只是说斯克兰顿的人太多了。是的。你知道吗？她说，“我在海滩上。”
Yeah. And she says, what is going to happen to our relationship? relationship if one of us gets this job. If I get this job, will you move to New York to be with me? And Jim is clearly uncomfortable. He's making jokes. He's trying to make jokes. Yeah. But Karen brings it around and she's like, actually, I'm kind of serious. Like after what happened on the beach, do I have a future with you? Because I don't feel like I have a future in Scranton, but I'd like to have a future with you. Well, she just says there's one too many people in Scranton. Yeah. You know? She was like, I was at the beach.
而且我不知道。他只是把它当作玩笑，然后抓住她的手，他们穿过马路。我敢肯定在内心深处，她知道他在犹豫。她一定知道。她试图练习良好的自我保健。她在这里试图照顾自己。她很自信。但她并没有真正读懂信号，我认为这些信号非常清晰。
And I don't know. He just sort of jokes it off and then grabs her hand and they cross the street. And I'm sure deep down, she knows that he's on the fence. She's got to know it. She's trying to practice good self-care. She is trying to take care of herself here. She's being assertive. But then she's not really reading the signals, which I think are super clear.
当你不想看到它们时，你永远读不懂它们。那是真的。把它印在 T 恤上。好的。所以现在是第二天早上。面试时间到了。凯伦、吉姆和迈克尔在大厅里等着。我应该承认这个事实，因为我之前对大厅只有一堆棕色棍子很刻薄，
You don't ever read them when you don't want to see them, though. That's true. Put that on a t-shirt. All right. So now it's the next morning. And it's interview time. Karen, Jim, and Michael are waiting in the lobby. I should own the fact, since I was snarky about the lobby, just having a bunch of brown sticks,
不过，你不想看的时候确实从来不会去读它们。没错。把这句话印在T恤上吧。好了。现在是第二天早上了。面试时间到了。凯伦、吉姆和迈克尔正在大厅里等着。我得承认，因为我之前对大厅里只有一堆棕色棍子发表了尖刻的评论，
that there is also a big plant on the other side of it. A big potted plant, everyone. Hey. A little bit of green in the corner. There you go. Mm-hmm. Well, that is nice. That's nice. And I'm sorry I was so snarky about your big brown sticks. Well, back at Dunder Mifflin, Dwight has appointed Andy as his number two officially. And Andy has accepted. And Jenna, we do that really cool thing, except now it's Dwight, where we start on him and we reveal Andy in the corner.
它的另一边还有一个大盆栽。大家看，一个大盆栽。嘿。角落里的一抹绿色。这就对了。嗯哼。嗯，那真不错。真不错。我很抱歉之前对你的那些大棕色棍子那么刻薄。好吧，回到邓德·米夫林，德怀特正式任命安迪为他的二把手。安迪接受了。珍娜，我们拍了那个非常酷的场景，除了现在换成了德怀特，我们从他开始，然后揭示角落里的安迪。
Yes. You know that's my favorite thing. I know. I know. I know. Andy has this talking head, and it's at 21 minutes, 54 seconds. He's saying, you know, three months ago, I was a Cornell grad and anger management, but look at me now. And he's washing out, you know, Dwight's mug. Jenna, can you hear that sink? Yeah. I couldn't not laugh because you and I know it's a fake sink. And it had that weird tinny sound because the water was going underneath into a bucket.
是的。你知道那是我最喜欢的部分。我知道。我知道。我知道。安迪有一个采访镜头，在21分54秒。他说，你知道，三个月前，我还是康奈尔大学的毕业生，还在上愤怒管理课，但看看现在的我。他正在洗德怀特的杯子。珍娜，你能听到那个水槽的声音吗？能。我忍不住笑了，因为你我都清楚那是个假水槽。它有一种奇怪的金属声，因为水直接流到了下面的桶里。
Yes, they had a little pump that would pump water through that faucet, but then it just came down the drain into a bucket. Yeah. There's no plumbing there. And then it would recycle. There's no plumbing. That's right. They would set it up and take it away.
是的，他们有一个小泵，可以把水抽到水龙头里，但水流出来后直接进了排水管下的桶里。是的。那里根本没有管道。然后水会循环使用。没有管道。没错。他们会把它装好，拍完再拆掉。
So something you could not do is improvise turning on the sink because nothing would come out. Or pour anything down the drain because it would just hit the ground. Correct. Correct. Well, now we have the scene where Dwight pulls Pam aside. He explains he's very impressed by her coal walk. and he would like her to be his secret assistant to the regional manager. And she accepts everything about the scene was delightful.
所以你无法即兴表演打开水槽，因为什么都不会流出来。或者把什么东西倒进下水道，因为它会直接掉到地上。没错。没错。好了，现在是德怀特把帕姆拉到一边的场景。他解释说他对她的走火炭表演印象非常深刻，他希望她能成为他秘密的区域经理助理。她接受了，关于这个场景的一切都很令人愉快。
I loved every single thing about it. I loved Dwight's bravado. And Pam's just like, uh-huh, uh-huh. Like, what an idiot, but I'm going to go along with it. Well, I think this is her way of staying connected to Jim. He's all the way in New York, but she has this talking head where she says she learned from Jim. If Dwight ever asks you to accept something in secret, you reply, absolutely I do. Yeah.
我喜欢关于它的一切。我喜欢德怀特的虚张声势。而帕姆只是说，嗯哼，嗯哼。就像是，真是个白痴，但我还是配合一下吧。嗯，我认为这是她与吉姆保持联系的方式。他远在纽约，但她有一个采访镜头，说她从吉姆那里学到了东西。如果德怀特让你秘密接受某件事，你就回答，我当然愿意。是的。
So I think throughout this whole episode when Pam is doing this little bit with Dwight, she is imagining how she's going to get to tell Jim all about it. Oh, for sure. For sure. Well, here is Dwight's team as he sees it. Dwight is the regional manager. Dwight is also the assistant regional manager. Andy is his number two because it's political. Pam is the secret assistant to their regional manager. And guess what? In a deleted scene, we find out that Angela is the spy in charge of the secret assistant to the regional manager. Oh, and what does that mean? Well, as soon as Pam says, yeah, absolutely I do and agrees to be the secret assistant to the regional manager, she leaves. And when she does, the scene plays out. Dwight calls Angela and says, keep an eye on Pam. And Angela's like, done. And then immediately my little head pops over the partition between accounting and reception. And I just start spying on you. Oh, that's amazing.
所以我认为在这一整集中，当帕姆和德怀特演这出戏时，她都在想象自己要如何把这一切告诉吉姆。哦，肯定的。肯定的。好吧，这是德怀特眼中的团队。德怀特是区域经理。德怀特也是区域经理助理。安迪是他的二把手，因为这是政治需要。帕姆是区域经理的秘密助理。你猜怎么着？在一个删减片段中，我们发现安吉拉是负责监视区域经理秘密助理的间谍。哦，那是什么意思？好吧，当帕姆说，是的，我当然愿意，并同意担任区域经理的秘密助理后，她就离开了。当她离开时，场景继续。德怀特打电话给安吉拉说，盯着帕姆。安吉拉说，没问题。然后我的小脑袋立刻从会计部和接待处之间的隔板上探了出来。我就开始监视你了。哦，太棒了。
I'm watching you. Oh, I wish they'd left that in. I know. It's a fun detail, right? I love that detail. Well, now, lady, we go back to corporate and Michael's interview has begun. Andy Buckley is so fantastic in this scene. I mean, Steve is always fantastic.
我在看着你。哦，我真希望他们把那段留下来。我知道。这是一个有趣的细节，对吧？我喜欢那个细节。好吧，现在，女士，我们回到总公司，迈克尔的面试开始了。安迪·巴克利在这个场景中太棒了。我是说，史蒂夫一直都很棒。
But to watch Steve as Michael, because Michael's so ridiculous, play off someone who's so believably a corporate person. It just was so fun to watch. So my favorite part of this scene with David and Michael is when he asked Michael where he sees room for improvement. And Michael's suggestion is that they rename the company altogether. Do you know his three names, right? His three suggestions? I wrote them down. Yeah.
但是看着史蒂夫扮演迈克尔，因为迈克尔太荒谬了，与一个如此可信的公司高管演对手戏。看这个过程真的很有趣。所以在这个场景中，我最喜欢大卫和迈克尔的部分是，当他问迈克尔他认为哪里有改进空间时。迈克尔的建议是他们干脆把公司改名。你知道他的三个名字，对吧？他的三个建议？我记下来了。是的。
Here are the names. Paper great. Great papers are passion. We're great. Super duper paper or just super duper. Yeah. Any of those. Any of those could work.
名字如下。Paper great（伟大的纸）。Great papers are passion（伟大的纸是激情）。We're great（我们很伟大）。Super duper paper（超级无敌纸）或者干脆叫Super duper（超级无敌）。是的。任何一个都可以。任何一个都能用。
Well, we had a fan question from Rebecca W. She said, were the suggestions Michael gave for a change of name of the company improvised? I checked the script. They were all in there with the exception of, super duper paper and super duper. Those were. But there was also way more to this interview scene.
好吧，我们有一个来自丽贝卡·W的粉丝提问。她说，迈克尔提出的公司改名建议是即兴发挥的吗？我查了剧本。它们都在剧本里，除了“Super duper paper”和“Super duper”。那些是即兴的。但这个面试场景里还有更多内容。
And I have to ask you, Angela, are they in the deleted scenes? Because they were so funny. There are so many deleted scenes for this particular episode. And this scene has several and they are hilarious. One of my favorite ones is that David says, what do you see in the future? You know, But he's meaning about the company. You know, where do you see the future going here? And Michael goes, he goes on about all this stuff. He goes on about how many kids he's going to have and all this stuff. But then he says, also, I think there could be one vitamin that you take for all of these other vitamins.
我得问你，安吉拉，它们在删减片段里吗？因为它们太搞笑了。这一集有太多的删减片段了。这个场景有几个，而且非常搞笑。我最喜欢的一个是大卫说，你对未来有什么看法？你知道，他是指关于公司。你知道，你觉得未来会怎样？迈克尔就开始说个不停。他说了他打算生多少孩子之类的废话。但后来他说，另外，我觉得可以有一种维生素，你吃了它就等于吃了所有其他的维生素。
But it's just one. I don't know. And David Wallace goes, you mean a multivitamin? And Michael's like, I don't know. going to call it. Like, I don't know. Yes. It is so funny, but there are great deleted scenes for this episode. That multivitamin thing was in the script, and it made me laugh out loud when I read it. It is hilarious. When he's like, I don't know what they're going to call it, but that's the idea. And David Wallace's look to him is just like, okay. And he's like, thanks for coming in, Michael.
但它只有一种。我不知道。大卫·华莱士说，你是说复合维生素吗？迈克尔说，我不知道。我不知道他们会叫它什么。就像，我不知道。是的。这太搞笑了，但这一集有很棒的删减片段。那个复合维生素的事情在剧本里，我读的时候笑出了声。这太搞笑了。当他说“我不知道他们会叫它什么，但这就是想法”时。大卫·华莱士看着他的眼神就像是，好吧。然后他说，谢谢你过来，迈克尔。
So, you know, Michael feels like he's had a pretty great interview. He's on his way out. And he says, oh, you should know that Jan and I are dating again, so I'm going to need to fill out one of those love documents. And David Wallace is like, well, you should know that this job you're interviewing for is to replace Jan. And Jenna, all I could think of was like, no, you can't tell Michael this kind of information. There is no way this man can hold on to that. You know what it made me think of Angela is when he says I need to sign another one of those love documents? I was like, It reminded me in dinner party when Michael explains he's had a vasectomy, but then had it reversed and then had a vasectomy and then reversed. I was like, how many of these documents have they been signing?
所以，你知道，迈克尔觉得他面试表现得相当不错。他正要离开。他说，哦，你应该知道简和我又在约会了，所以我需要填一份那种恋爱关系文件。大卫·华莱士说，嗯，你应该知道你面试的这个职位是为了取代简。珍娜，我当时想的是，不，你不能告诉迈克尔这种信息。这个男人根本藏不住事。你知道这让我想到了什么吗，安吉拉，当他说他需要再签一份恋爱关系文件时？我想到了在《晚宴》那一集中，迈克尔解释说他做了输精管结扎术，然后又做了复通手术，然后又做了结扎，然后又复通。我在想，他们到底签了多少份这种文件？
It's like, we're on, we're off, we're on, we're off. And I wonder also if they had dramatic ripping in half of the document. Yes, I have so many questions about the love document. But I agree with you, this news to Michael that the job he's applying for is, Jan's job and she doesn't know yet that she's going to be let go. This is a secret that you should not allow Michael to hold. You can't tell Michael any secret. You couldn't say, hey, don't tell anyone, but I have toe fungus. Forget it. The next thing out of his mouth would be, I'm so sorry, you have toe fungus in front of everyone. Yes. Yes. I don't have toe fungus. I was just trying to
就像是，我们在一起，我们分手，我们在一起，我们分手。我还想知道他们是否上演过戏剧性地撕毁文件的戏码。是的，我对恋爱关系文件有很多疑问。但我同意你的看法，迈克尔得知他申请的职位是简的职位，而她还不知道自己要被解雇。这是一个不应该让迈克尔知道的秘密。你不能告诉迈克尔任何秘密。你不能说，嘿，别告诉任何人，但我有脚气。算了吧。他脱口而出的下一句话就是，我很抱歉，你在大家面前有脚气。是的。是的。我没有脚气。我只是在试着
think of something. I have fungus on my toenails. I know, but you treat. did it and it's all better. It came back. It did. Yeah. You know, if you wear nail polish long enough and your toenails don't get a good amount of oxygen, you can get in, you know, it's, by the way, everyone, toe fungus is just like, on your toenail, it's just like a little white spot.
想点什么。我的脚趾甲上有真菌。我知道，但你治疗了它，现在全好了。它又复发了。确实。你知道，如果你涂指甲油的时间太长，脚趾甲得不到足够的氧气，你就会得，你知道，顺便说一下，大家，脚趾甲真菌就像是，在你的脚趾甲上，只是一个小小白点。
Yeah. That's what those white spots are, everyone. If you're like, what are these white spots on my toenails when I take off my nail polished, that's toe fungus, y'all. And you can get a special, like, oil and polish to put on there to get rid of it if you care. Well, my mom always would say every once in a while just take your toenail polish off and let your toenails breathe. It's good advice. It's not pretty. You're going to have a week of, like, funky-looking yellow toes. Sorry. All right, sorry, sorry, sorry. Where are we? Well, we need to go back to Dunder Mithlin because Dwight would like everyone to gather in the conference
是的。大家，那些白点就是那个。如果你在想，当我卸掉指甲油时，脚趾甲上的这些白点是什么，那就是脚趾甲真菌，伙计们。如果你在意的话，你可以买一种特殊的油和指甲油涂在上面把它去掉。好吧，我妈妈总是说偶尔把指甲油卸掉，让脚趾甲透透气。这是个好建议。这并不好看。你会有一周的时间，脚趾看起来黄黄的，很奇怪。抱歉。好吧，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。我们说到哪了？好吧，我们需要回到邓德·米夫林，因为德怀特想让大家在会议室集合
room, he needs to discuss and introduce the Shrewd-Buck reward system. It was so funny to me. You know what I loved about this? First of all, at 25 minutes, three seconds, Angela's so proud. She's so proud. She has this look. Yes, Dwight is calling his first conference room meeting. She is, can't believe it. But I love how he leads everyone in. He's like, no more meetings, right? Michael had all these useless meetings. Instead, we're going to have lectures. Yes. And Pam, Pam can't wait. She's like, what is he going to do? I can't wait. I can't wait to see what's about to happen. Well, we get in there and we start getting our first lecture. And it is about the origin of paper making. Yeah. He starts
他需要讨论并介绍“Schrute-Buck”奖励系统。这对我来说太搞笑了。你知道我喜欢这个的什么吗？首先，在25分3秒，安吉拉太骄傲了。她太骄傲了。她有那种表情。是的，德怀特正在召开他的第一次会议室会议。她简直不敢相信。但我喜欢他引导大家进去的方式。他说，不再有会议了，对吧？迈克尔以前有那么多没用的会议。相反，我们要进行讲座。是的。帕姆，帕姆等不及了。她说，他要干什么？我等不及了。我等不及要看接下来会发生什么。好吧，我们进去了，开始听我们的第一次讲座。是关于造纸的起源。是的。他开始
with a bunch of Tupperatins full of soil, different types of soil. And he asked the question, what would you say is the most important element in the production of above-ground leafy growth? You probably think it's phosphorus. And then Angela secretly shakes her head no. I improvised that, and our camera operator caught it and was like, oh, that's so good. Ken loved it, and he told me to keep doing it. I loved it. Like, I obviously knew this speech that Dwight had practiced it for me.
拿出一堆装满土壤的特百惠盒子，不同类型的土壤。他问了一个问题，你会说在地上叶片生长生产中最关键的元素是什么？你可能会认为是磷。然后安吉拉偷偷摇了摇头。那是我即兴发挥的，我们的摄像师捕捉到了它，说，哦，那太好了。肯很喜欢，他让我继续这样做。我喜欢它。就像，我显然知道德怀特为我练习过这个演讲。
I used to love having those moments. I'm sure he practiced it for you. He's killing it. According to you, you're like, he's killing it. Crushing it. By the way, the answer is nitrogen. Per Dwight. Lady, I had to know.
我以前很喜欢那些时刻。我相信他为你练习过。他表现得太棒了。按照你的说法，你就像是，他表现得太棒了。太强了。顺便说一下，答案是氮。德怀特说的。女士，我必须知道。
Did you look it up? Did you look up phosphorus? You know that website, Quora? Yeah. It's where you post a question about something and then experts on that subject weigh in. Did you post the question? I didn't post the question. Oh, I got real excited.
你查了吗？你查过磷了吗？你知道那个叫Quora的网站吗？是的。那是你发布关于某事的问题，然后该领域的专家会发表意见的地方。你发布那个问题了吗？我没发布那个问题。哦，我当时真的很兴奋。
But years ago, Someone posted that exact question. The wording was exact. Exactly what Dwight says. There was an office fan years ago that was like, wait, is this true? So it's really amazing the back and forth from all the people who are not realizing that this is a direct quote from an office episode. It is just soil scientists weighing in. There's charts.
但几年前，有人发布了那个确切的问题。措辞完全一样。正是德怀特所说的。几年前有个办公室粉丝说，等等，这是真的吗？所以那些没有意识到这是《办公室》剧集直接引用的人，他们的来回讨论真的很神奇。这只是土壤科学家在发表意见。有图表。
There's pages and pages of these scientists debating what. What is the most important element in the production of above-ground leafy growth? And the consensus is nitrogen. How? Nitrogen. Way to go, Dwight. Way to go. Jenna, do you remember filming the scene?
有几页又几页的科学家在争论什么。什么是地上叶片生长生产中最关键的元素？共识是氮。怎么会？氮。干得好，德怀特。干得好。珍娜，你还记得拍摄那个场景吗？
Because I remember the smell. Can we talk about it for a second? We can. There was an earthy smell. Now, you know this room had no real windows. So it's like sitting in a box. Now, it didn't have a full ceiling, but we were sort of trapped in there with smell. smells. Oh, yeah. And there was a real dirt smell. And then it's in the deleted scenes. You guys don't
因为我记得那个味道。我们可以谈谈它吗？可以。有一种泥土味。现在，你知道这个房间没有真正的窗户。所以就像坐在盒子里一样。现在，它没有完整的天花板，但我们被困在那里，闻着各种味道。哦，是的。有一种真正的泥土味。而且它在删减片段里。你们没有
get to see it. But Dwight actually starts by dumping a whole bunch of trash on the table. I remember that. To talk to everyone about recycling. So we had some earthy, trashy smells going. Yeah, it was intense. We also have the great moment, which is one of my favorite moments where Stanley does not want to participate. He won a shrewbook, but he doesn't want it. No, he doesn't want it. He does not want to participate in any of this. And Dwight is like, you don't want your shrewbuck? And he's like, no. And then he offers him like a thousand Stanley Nichols to leave him alone. A billion. A billion Stanley Nichols, if you never speak to me again. Yes, thank you. It's brilliant. And Dwight's response is he would like to know the conversion rate between Stanley Nichols and troop
看到它。但德怀特实际上是从把一堆垃圾倒在桌子上开始的。我记得那个。为了和大家谈论回收利用。所以我们有一些泥土味和垃圾味。是的，这很强烈。我们还有一个伟大的时刻，这是我最喜欢的时刻之一，斯坦利不想参与。他赢了一个Schrute-Buck，但他不想要。不，他不想要。他不想参与任何这些。德怀特说，你不想要你的Schrute-Buck吗？他说，不。然后他给了他一千个斯坦利镍币让他别烦他。十亿。十亿个斯坦利镍币，如果你再也不跟我说话的话。是的，谢谢。这太天才了。德怀特的反应是他想知道斯坦利镍币和Schrute-Buck之间的汇率
bugs. And it's the same as leprechauns to unicorns. Yeah. And then, Jenna, you must have had so much fun because then everyone starts to be like, I'm out of here. I don't want to do this. And Pam is like, hey, pay attention. Lady, when I heard that delivery, now this was before I had children, but when I heard my voice, I was like, oh my gosh, That's the voice when I have to lay down the law with the kids. When I'm like, listen to me. I've asked three times to brush our teeth. It's time to brush teeth now.
这和妖精对独角兽的汇率一样。是的。然后，珍娜，你一定玩得很开心，因为每个人都开始说，我走了。我不想做这个。帕姆说，嘿，注意听。女士，当我听到那个语气时，这还是在我有孩子之前，但当我听到我的声音时，我想，哦，天哪，这就是我必须对孩子们立规矩时的声音。当我像是，听我说。我已经问了三次去刷牙了。现在是刷牙的时间了。
Hustle, go to the bathroom. I was like, oh, my gosh, that is my mom voice. That's my mom voice. That's your mom getting line voice. Yeah, that's right. Yeah. For sure. I was shocked.
快点，去洗手间。我想，哦，天哪，那是我的妈妈声音。那是我的妈妈声音。那是你妈妈在管教时的声音。是的，没错。是的。肯定的。我惊呆了。
You had it in you all along. I did. It was meant to be. Well, there's a nice little moment that I think Phyllis just improvised. And we often did things like this in the background. We just sort of made up our own story if we didn't have dialogue of how we would react to these moments. And she's sleeping. I know. I noticed that too. Minutes 29 seconds. I thought that was an amazing choice. Yeah. An amazing choice. Well, listen, lady, we're about to go back to corporate. We're going to see Karen interview with David.
你一直都有这种潜质。我确实有。这是命中注定的。好吧，有一个很好的小瞬间，我认为菲利斯只是即兴发挥的。我们经常在背景中做这样的事情。如果我们没有对话，我们就会编造自己的故事，关于我们如何对这些时刻做出反应。她在睡觉。我知道。我也注意到了。29分秒。我觉得那是一个很棒的选择。是的。一个很棒的选择。好吧，听着，女士，我们要回到总公司了。我们要看凯伦和大卫的面试。
I think we should take a break. I think we should take a break and come back because Karen is crushing her interview. We need to get to it. She's doing really well. Yeah. All right. We'll be right back. Okay.
我觉得我们应该休息一下。我觉得我们应该休息一下再回来，因为凯伦的面试表现得太棒了。我们需要讲到那里。她做得非常好。是的。好吧。我们马上回来。好的。
We are back from break. Karen is being interviewed before we get into that. Jenna, I had to look up the limelight one more time because I was pretty sure. And in fact, this is correct. There is a documentary. about the history of the limelight, this huge part of New York's culture. I'm sorry to go on and on about it,
我们休息回来了。凯伦正在接受面试，在我们进入那个话题之前。珍娜，我不得不再次查了一下Limelight（聚光灯夜店），因为我很确定。事实上，这是正确的。有一部纪录片。关于Limelight的历史，这是纽约文化中巨大的一部分。我很抱歉一直喋喋不休地谈论它，
but I think I want to watch this documentary. Number one, I will be watching that documentary tonight. Number two, you do not need to apologize for your interest in the limelight or for the interesting facts that you shared with us because, lady, I want to say something. We got this really nice letter from a fan. And in it, she said,
但我认为我想看这部纪录片。第一，我今晚会看那部纪录片。第二，你不需要为你的兴趣或你与我们分享的有趣事实道歉，因为，女士，我想说点什么。我们收到了一封来自粉丝的非常好的信。在信中，她说，
I just need to tell you that you guys do not need to apologize for going off subject. You guys always apologize for it. And I love it. It's a great part of the podcast. And you know what, lady, it got me thinking. That is a thing. Hold on. Soapbox coming out. That is a very common thing that women do. Women apologize all the time for things they don't need to apologize about. And I think we do not need to apologize for our deep dives. we do not need to apologize for the things that interest us or for our banter that comes to us in the moment while making this podcast, I don't apologize. I don't apologize. I like how by the end of that speech, you had like an affected way of talking. You were like, I don't apologize. I don't apologize for that either. Well, you know, that has been something I've sort of struggled with, I guess, my whole life. I don't know. I think I used to say I'm sorry about everything. I don't know. I would say I'm sorry about the most ridiculous things. Like, My chair would squeak. I'd be like, oh, I'm sorry.
我只是需要告诉你们，你们不需要为偏离主题而道歉。你们总是为此道歉。我喜欢它。这是播客中很棒的一部分。你知道吗，女士，这让我开始思考。这是一回事。等等。肥皂箱要拿出来了。这是女性非常普遍的做法。女性总是为她们不需要道歉的事情道歉。我认为我们不需要为我们的深度挖掘道歉。我们不需要为我们感兴趣的事情或我们在制作这个播客时即兴产生的闲聊道歉，我不道歉。我不道歉。我喜欢你演讲结束时那种做作的说话方式。你说，我不道歉。我也不为此道歉。好吧，你知道，这确实是我一生中一直在挣扎的事情，我想。我不知道。我想我以前对每件事都说对不起。我不知道。我会为最荒谬的事情说对不起。比如，我的椅子吱吱作响。我会说，哦，对不起。
Or I'd reach for a glass of water the same time someone else would. I'd be like, oh, I'm sorry. Yes. Or like how many times have you been walking down the street and someone bumps into you and you say, oh, sorry. What? I'm sorry for taking up the space. My body requires to walk down the street. You walked into me.
或者我和别人同时去拿一杯水。我会说，哦，对不起。是的。或者你走在街上，有人撞到你，你说，哦，对不起。什么？我为占据了我的身体走在街上所需的空间而道歉？是你撞到了我。
Why am I apologizing? It's a thing that women do. We do. I mean, it's not just women, but there's this, I just, I notice it. we got that nice letter, I thought, this is the coaching I needed. This is good. Well, I appreciate that letter. I think I think I probably had read a comment that probably wasn't healthy where this guy said we talked about appetizers for eight minutes and he wanted to drive his car into a pole. And I was like, oh, no. But you know what? You know what I want to say to
我为什么要道歉？这是女性会做的事情。我们确实会。我的意思是，不仅仅是女性，但我注意到了。我们收到了那封好信，我想，这是我需要的指导。这很好。好吧，我很感激那封信。我想我可能读过一条不太健康的评论，那个家伙说我们谈论开胃菜谈了八分钟，他想把车开进电线杆里。我想，哦，不。但你知道吗？你知道我想对那个男人说什么吗？
that man? Listen, Mr. I'm sorry, sometimes we're going to talk about appetizers and we're going to talk about bars that used to be in a church and pockets and Clementine Paddleford. And you know what? I really want to encourage you to do with love, hit fast forward. Angela, you are right. You don't have to listen to anything you don't want to, but we also get to talk about what we want. Right? Yeah. Without apology. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. And good day. And good day to you. And now Karen is crushing her interview 28 minutes, 58 seconds. I thought she was going to get the job. Well, she should get the job. I mean, really, it was between her and Jim. I think it was theirs to lose. And David Wallace clearly has like a man crush on Jim. Well, we noticed this back when David threw his party and he wanted to go shoot hoops with Jim.
听着，先生，有时候我们会谈论开胃菜，我们会谈论曾经在教堂里的酒吧，口袋和克莱门汀·帕德尔福德。你知道吗？我真的想带着爱鼓励你做一件事，按快进键。安吉拉，你是对的。你不必听任何你不想听的东西，但我们也可以谈论我们想谈的东西。对吧？是的。无需道歉。是的。谢谢。谢谢。祝你今天愉快。也祝你今天愉快。现在凯伦的面试表现得太棒了，28分58秒。我以为她会得到这份工作。好吧，她应该得到这份工作。我的意思是，真的，这是她和吉姆之间的竞争。我认为这是他们应得的。大卫·华莱士显然对吉姆有种“男人崇拜”。好吧，我们早在大卫举办派对，想和吉姆一起投篮时就注意到了这一点。
I mean, I don't want to get my soapbox out again so soon. But this happens in the male corporate culture. There's all these ways and activities that men have to bond between men and it's been difficult for women to you know get in there they got their golfing and their shooting of the hoops and you know yeah well while this is going on these interviews i just said i was sorry to get out my soapbox oh my god i did it again i just apologized i can't stop it we can't stop it we will stop we'll try we'll try Okay, so listen, while Karen is interviewing, Michael goes to Jan's office. Nope, nope, he should have just kept on walking. He immediately tells her that she's going to be fired.
我的意思是，我不想这么快就把我的肥皂箱拿出来。但这在男性企业文化中确实会发生。男人之间有很多建立联系的方式和活动，女性一直很难融入其中。他们有高尔夫，有投篮，你知道，是的，好吧，当这一切发生时，这些面试，我刚才说我很抱歉拿出我的肥皂箱，哦，天哪，我又做了！我又道歉了，我停不下来，我们停不下来，我们会停下来的，我们会尝试的，我们会尝试的。好的，听着，当凯伦在面试时，迈克尔去了简的办公室。不，不，他应该继续走。他立刻告诉她她要被解雇了。
She's being replaced. So, of course, Jan storms in to Karen's interview and starts yelling at him. She says, hey, you son of a bitch. Like, just right away. And David is so calm. We talked about this last week with Paul, where Paul really admired David for being so pointed and calm during this moment. And he says, Jan, this is long overdue. Long overdue.
她要被取代了。所以，当然，简冲进了凯伦的面试现场，开始对他大喊大叫。她说，嘿，你这个混蛋。就像，直接就说了。大卫非常冷静。我们上周和保罗谈过这个，保罗真的很钦佩大卫在这一刻表现得如此尖锐和冷静。他说，简，这早就该发生了。早就该发生了。
You've shown no interest in your job lately. We can never get a hold of you. Very erratic behavior. Like your head's not here. You're not here. He calls her unstable. Yeah. And then Michael's like, you're unstable.
你最近对你的工作表现得毫无兴趣。我们永远找不到你。行为非常古怪。就像你的心思不在这里。你人也不在这里。他称她不稳定。是的。然后迈克尔说，你不稳定。
And then David's like, I'm sorry, what? And Michael's like, never mind. We're all unstable. What's happening? Michael also insists he didn't tell her. Yeah. It wasn't me. While hiding behind the partition.
然后大卫说，对不起，你说什么？迈克尔说，没关系。我们都不稳定。发生了什么？迈克尔还坚持说他没告诉她。是的。不是我。同时躲在隔板后面。
I didn't say anything. Well, Jan asks if this is because of her new boobs. Because Michael loves them. And she doesn't care. Yeah. He loves them. That's all that matters to her. Well, then she's been.
我什么都没说。好吧，简问这是不是因为她的新胸部。因为迈克尔喜欢它们。她不在乎。是的。他喜欢它们。这对她来说才是最重要的。好吧，然后她被
being escorted out of the office. She's got a bunch of stuff. She hugs Hunter. Her whole scene with Hunter is brilliant. She's like, good luck with the band. Don't let them change you here. It's so good. Well, she drops a bunch of her stuff on the ground and Hunter and Michael are trying to help her pick it up. And Lady, did you know that was not supposed to happen? I did know that. I did know that because they talk about it in the DVD commentary. Malora said she had this box full of like what was Jan's belongings, right? And it was sort of an awkward, different shaped items and a few things spilled out. And Ken did not yell cut. He just let the scene play out. And Michael and Hunter, everyone just stayed in the moment. They're trying to help her put things back. And Malara said
护送出了办公室。她拿了一堆东西。她拥抱了亨特。她和亨特的整个场景都很精彩。她说，祝你的乐队好运。别让他们在这里改变你。这太棒了。好吧，她把一堆东西掉在了地上，亨特和迈克尔试图帮她捡起来。女士，你知道那不是预先安排好的吗？我知道。我知道，因为他们在DVD评论中谈到了这一点。马洛拉说她有一个装满简的私人物品的盒子，对吧？那是一些尴尬的、形状各异的物品，有些东西洒了出来。肯没有喊停。他只是让场景继续进行。迈克尔和亨特，每个人都沉浸在那个时刻。他们试图帮她把东西放回去。马洛拉说
they actually had a hard time getting everything to fit back in. And that's why that played out so long, but everyone's reactions are perfect. David's like, what's happening? And then you have Jim and Karen. That was all unscripted. I love stuff like that. I love that. And you know, it reminds me, Angela, when I've had to do scenes where I have to carry a lot of stuff, a lot of times they'll give you like a suitcase that's empty or they'll give you a bag and it doesn't really have much in it. And I had to shoot this scene where I was coming through the door and I had all this junk. And I said, will you make it real? Yeah.
他们实际上很难把所有东西都装回去。这就是为什么那段戏演了那么久，但每个人的反应都很完美。大卫说，发生了什么？然后你有吉姆和凯伦。那都是即兴的。我喜欢那样的东西。我喜欢那个。你知道，这让我想起，安吉拉，当我必须拍摄需要携带很多东西的场景时，很多时候他们会给你一个空的行李箱，或者他们会给你一个包，里面其实没装什么东西。我必须拍摄那个我走进门的场景，我带着所有这些垃圾。我说，你们能让它变得真实吗？是的。
Because I think that if I'm really struggling with it, if I'm not pretending to struggle with it, it'll just be better. And I swear every time I would do the scene, some other insane thing would happen. And it was so much better than if I was faking it. Yeah. And so because these are the moments, right? Yeah. was a real life moment and everyone rolled with it and it was so funny it's so funny but you're right those real moments that that the camera captures when we're playing make believe like i always think
因为我认为如果我真的在为它挣扎，如果我不是假装在挣扎，那会更好。我发誓每次我拍那个场景，都会发生其他疯狂的事情。这比我假装要好得多。是的。因为这就是那些时刻，对吧？是的。这是一个真实生活的时刻，每个人都顺其自然，这太搞笑了，太搞笑了。但你是对的，那些摄像机捕捉到的真实时刻，当我们假装的时候，就像我总是
about that famous scene on friends where they're trying to get that sofa up the stairwell and ross is yelling pivot pivot and they're all holding the sofa like these are these moments i love because it's like real life but milora did say one thing she said said, if you notice, if you watch the scene, the whole time we're picking up items and putting them back in the box, you do not see my face because I bent over as far as I could so my hair would hide my face because I am laughing so hard. I love that. I'm going to go back and look at that. Well, Michael then tells David, hey, just let me know about the job. Let me know when you know.
想到《老友记》里那个著名的场景，他们试图把沙发搬上楼梯，罗斯在大喊“旋转，旋转”，他们都抓着沙发，这些时刻我都很喜欢，因为这就像真实生活。但马洛拉确实说了一件事，她说，如果你注意看，如果你看那个场景，我们一直在捡东西放回盒子里，你看不到我的脸，因为我弯下腰尽可能低，这样我的头发就能遮住我的脸，因为我笑得太厉害了。我喜欢那个。我要回去看看。好吧，迈克尔然后告诉大卫，嘿，关于工作的事告诉我一声。你知道的时候告诉我。
And David is like, you're not getting the job. Yeah. And so then, of course, Michael is like, I withdraw myself from consideration. Do you accept my withdrawal? David's like, yeah. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. And then Michael's like, but do I get to keep my job at Scranton?
大卫说，你得不到这份工作。是的。所以，当然，迈克尔说，我撤回我的申请。你接受我的撤回吗？大卫说，是的。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。然后迈克尔说，但我能保住我在斯克兰顿的工作吗？
And David's like, yes. And he goes, good, because that's all I ever really wanted. Well, speaking of Scranton, Michael's going to be in for a surprise because Andy and Dwight are painting Dwight's new office, Michael's old office, soon to be office again, black. They're painting all the walls black. Well, Michael's going to be really surprised because he also, in a deleted scene, told Dwight, don't do anything to my office for one month out of sort of like morning, like, morning, like, Don't touch anything for one month to honor my absence.
大卫说，是的。他说，好，因为那是我真正想要的。好吧，说到斯克兰顿，迈克尔要大吃一惊了，因为安迪和德怀特正在把德怀特的新办公室，也就是迈克尔的旧办公室，很快又要变回来的办公室，漆成黑色。他们正在把所有的墙都漆成黑色。好吧，迈克尔会非常惊讶，因为他在一个删减片段中告诉德怀特，一个月内不要动我的办公室，作为一种哀悼，就像，不要碰任何东西一个月，以纪念我的缺席。
And Dwight immediately starts painting it black. We had a lot of questions about how we did this. They did not paint the real walls. They brought in other fake walls that were black. Yeah. So we did not paint the walls that were Michael's office. They made dummy walls. And then they could take them down.
德怀特立刻开始把它漆成黑色。我们有很多关于我们是如何做到这一点的问题。他们没有漆真正的墙。他们带来了其他黑色的假墙。是的。所以我们没有漆迈克尔办公室的墙。他们做了假墙。然后他们可以把它们拆下来。
Yes. And the old walls were right behind. Yes, very easily. But they were really painting. And they had different panels of these fake walls that they would paint throughout this scene. But, yeah, it was very easy to reset it back to the original Michael's office. Well, Jenna, back in New York, one of the things we didn't talk about was Jim and Karen's reaction to Jan's big meltdown. I mean, Karen's like, wow, that was really self-destructive.
是的。旧墙就在后面。是的，非常容易。但他们确实在漆。他们有这些假墙的不同面板，他们会在这个场景中漆它们。但是，是的，把它重置回原来的迈克尔办公室非常容易。好吧，珍娜，回到纽约，我们没谈论的一件事是吉姆和凯伦对简大崩溃的反应。我的意思是，凯伦说，哇，那真是自毁行为。
And Jim is like, I kind of feel bad for her. Yeah, Karen does not feel bad for her. Yeah, Karen's like, I don't know. I think she's not having any sympathy for jam. No, Karen is done. She is done with these folks. Well, speaking of done, Jim still has to go into his interview. And I thought this was interesting. Jim was like, hey, you know, if you want to take off, I can just, you know, meet you later. And Karen kind of jumps on it. She's like, yeah, actually, I wanted to meet some friends downtown for lunch. Do you mind? Now I didn't I didn't see that as like weird that seemed like what you know if she's just sitting in a lobby just waiting for him and she does have friends who are eating like couldn't she go meet them and then he come after? I don't know. I'm just imagining like if Lee and I had gone to New York and we were both going for an important meeting in the same building and my meeting was first and he had to wait for me. I would just be like, I'll wait for you. so that I'm the first face you see after your meeting and you can tell me all about it.
吉姆说，我有点为她感到难过。是的，凯伦并不为她感到难过。是的，凯伦说，我不知道。我觉得她对简一点同情心都没有。不，凯伦受够了。她受够了这些人。好吧，说到受够了，吉姆还得去面试。我觉得这很有趣。吉姆说，嘿，你知道，如果你想走，我可以，你知道，稍后再见你。凯伦有点顺水推舟。她说，是的，其实我想去市中心见几个朋友吃午饭。你介意吗？现在我没觉得那很奇怪，那看起来像是，你知道，如果她只是坐在大厅里等他，而她确实有朋友在吃饭，难道她不能去见他们，然后他再过去吗？我不知道。我只是在想象，如果李和我去了纽约，我们俩都要在同一栋楼里参加重要的会议，我的会议先开始，他必须等我。我会说，我会等你。这样你面试后我就是你看到的第一个人，你可以把一切都告诉我。
That's so sweet. That's so sweet. That's so sweet. Clearly, I'm like, okay, meet me for lunch. I'll be having me missus. Bye. Good luck, babe. See you in a bit.
那太甜了。那太甜了。那太甜了。显然，我像是，好的，午饭见。我会去吃我的。再见。祝你好运，宝贝。一会儿见。
I don't know. I just sort of like, if I don't have anywhere that I have to be. Now, listen, I do get it. She's in New York for a brief period of time. Maybe this is her only chance to see these friends. That's what I thought. I thought, you know, she had friends. there if she never gets to see and they're like when you're done with your interview meet us for lunch and she's
我不知道。我只是觉得，如果我没有必须去的地方。现在，听着，我确实明白了。她在纽约待的时间很短。也许这是她见这些朋友的唯一机会。我就是这么想的。我想，你知道，她在那里有朋友，她从没机会见到他们，他们就像，当你面试完后，来见我们吃午饭，她
like oh my god yeah but now now jan has had this whole meltdown and maybe things the timing of the interviews got pushed back a little and she's going to miss lunch and i maybe i don't know but i mean think about that i'm like thinking forward like so now when jim gets out of this big interview he's not going to have karen alone he has to walk into a restaurant with her and all her friends and how'd your interview go good We can't talk about it right now, though. I don't know. This is a big deal. It's a big interview.
说，哦，天哪，是的。但现在简发生了这一切崩溃，也许面试的时间被推迟了一点，她要错过午饭了，我可能，我不知道，但我的意思是，想想看，我是在向前思考，所以现在当吉姆从这个大面试中出来时，他不会有凯伦单独陪他，他必须和她以及她所有的朋友一起走进一家餐厅，面试怎么样？好。不过我们现在不能谈这个。我不知道。这是一件大事。这是一个重要的面试。
I think there's room for, like, intimate support. I don't know. Well, they're clearly not meant to be together. Well, I don't know. I think Pam would have waited. I think Pam would have waited, too. I don't know if that's a good thing or a bad thing. And I think Jenna Fisher would have waited.
我觉得有空间进行那种亲密的支持。我不知道。好吧，他们显然不适合在一起。好吧，我不知道。我觉得帕姆会等的。我觉得帕姆也会等的。我不知道这是好事还是坏事。而且我觉得珍娜·费舍尔也会等的。
I would have waited, too. Angel's on the fence. Angel's on the fence. It depends on the fence. restaurant and how bad you want the job well listen now we cut to the car ride back to scranton with jan and michael and lady this reminded me of jan's car moment in cocktails she falls apart in a car ride guys what is it about car rides and jan there you know what is it because the cameras are tiny and jan forgets that she's on camera and she this is like her confessional
我也会等的。安吉拉在犹豫。安吉拉在犹豫。这取决于餐厅，以及你有多想要这份工作。好吧，听着，现在我们切到简和迈克尔回斯克兰顿的车程，女士，这让我想起了简在《鸡尾酒》里的车内时刻。她在车里崩溃了，伙计们，车程和简之间到底有什么？你知道，这是什么？因为摄像机很小，简忘了她在镜头前，这是她的忏悔室
is the car. Best stuff comes from Jan in a car. I think it's a couple's thing. I really do because I think you hold it together while you're at the party or the school assembly or the soccer match or shopping at IKEA wherever you are and something goes down. You hold it in and then you get in the car and then you either let each other have it or you start laughing or one of you cries. Like that's the moment where you're like, oh my God. You are right. We use. I had a group of friends when I was like starting out here in comedy. And like if we were out somewhere and we saw a couple kind of have a little tiff moment, like at a bar or something, we'd all whisper car ride home, car ride home.
就是车。简最好的东西都来自车里。我认为这是情侣之间的事情。我真的这么认为，因为我认为你在派对、学校集会、足球比赛或在宜家购物时，无论你在哪里，都会保持冷静，然后发生了什么事。你忍着，然后你上车，然后你们要么互相发泄，要么开始大笑，要么其中一个人哭了。就像那是你觉得，哦，天哪，的时刻。你是对的。我们用。当我刚开始做喜剧时，我有一群朋友。如果我们出去，看到一对情侣在酒吧之类的地方有点小争执，我们都会低声说“车程回家，车程回家”。
Like it is not going to go well. Well, I love it. I can't get enough of Jan in the car. I can't get enough. She starts crying. She's like, it's these pain killers. They gave me after my boob job. And then she's like, oh, wait, this could work.
就像这不会有好结果。好吧，我喜欢它。我怎么看简在车里都看不够。我怎么看都不够。她开始哭。她说，是这些止痛药。我做完隆胸手术后他们给我的。然后她说，哦，等等，这行得通。
Like her emotions are going up and down. She's like, I could wear stretch pants. and wait for you to come home at 5.15. Yes, she invites herself to move in with Michael. Yeah. And Michael is like, what? Oh. Well, he, come on.
就像她的情绪起伏不定。她说，我可以穿紧身裤，等着你5点15分回家。是的，她邀请自己搬去和迈克尔住。是的。迈克尔说，什么？哦。好吧，他，得了吧。
He walked himself into that. He was like, I guess you could move in with me and my condo. I guess I could get it back. I'd probably get a negative review on my eBay account. But it's like at the beginning of this episode, he asks all of the ladies to help him not get back together with Jan, and it ends with them moving in together. Yeah. And she doesn't have a job, and she's spiraling.
他自己走进了那个陷阱。他说，我想你可以搬进我的公寓和我住。我想我可以把它拿回来。我可能会在我的eBay账户上得到差评。但就像在这一集的开头，他请求所有的女士帮他不要和简复合，结果却以他们住在一起告终。是的。而且她没有工作，她正在失控。
It's a lot. Well, Michael comes back into the office. He announces he has withdrawn his name from contention. He notices that his office is now painted black. I liked this bit. He tells Ryan to go get him a coffee, and Ryan said he doesn't do that. stuff anymore? And he says, no, it's for me, Bimbo, kids. Yeah, I know. Oh, Ryan is about to have his moment. And this is when Pam asks, did Karen get the job? Yeah, I don't know. Someone's real curious.
这太多了。好吧，迈克尔回到办公室。他宣布他已经撤回了他的名字。他注意到他的办公室现在被漆成了黑色。我喜欢这个片段。他让瑞安去给他买杯咖啡，瑞安说他不再做那种事了？他说，不，这是给我的，笨蛋，孩子。是的，我知道。哦，瑞安要迎来他的时刻了。这时帕姆问，凯伦得到这份工作了吗？是的，我不知道。有人真的很好奇。
Michael has a whole speech here that is sort of heartbreaking. He says, yeah, so I'm going nowhere, never going to leave. This place is going to be the hospital where I was born. my house, my old age home, my graveyard for my bones. And the camera pans across everyone's faces. Like, this isn't good news for anybody. Yeah, it's true. And then Dwight's back at his desk. This is a sweet moment.
迈克尔在这里有一段演讲，有点令人心碎。他说，是的，所以我哪儿也不去，永远不会离开。这个地方将是我出生的医院，我的家，我的养老院，我骨头的坟墓。摄像机扫过每个人的脸。就像，这对任何人来说都不是好消息。是的，这是真的。然后德怀特回到他的办公桌。这是一个甜蜜的时刻。
I love these sweet moments between Pam and Dwight, where he thanks Pam for serving with great dignity. And she salutes him, and he salutes her back. Yeah. It's kind of their version of the air. High five. Well, you know, Dwight goes on to say eventually that Pam is his best friend. Yeah. You know. It's so sweet. Well, this is something that probably most people didn't catch, but at 35 minutes, 34 seconds, in the background and accounting, Brian, as Kevin sort of improvises this moment, when Michael's saying that he's back and he's like doing all that weird stuff, he's like, I'm back, right? Yes, yes. It's good. I'm back. Anyway, Kevin sort of leans over to Anne.
我喜欢帕姆和德怀特之间这些甜蜜的时刻，他感谢帕姆以极大的尊严服务。她向他敬礼，他也向她回礼。是的。这算是他们版本的空中击掌。好吧，你知道，德怀特最终说帕姆是他最好的朋友。是的。你知道。这太甜了。好吧，这是大多数人可能没注意到的事情，但在35分34秒，在会计部的背景里，布莱恩，当凯文即兴发挥这个时刻时，当迈克尔说他回来了，他在做所有那些奇怪的事情，他说，我回来了，对吧？是的，是的。这很好。我回来了。总之，凯文有点向安倾斜。
Angela and Brian improvised this. He was like, so wait, did he get the job? And I just shake my head. I'm like, no. And you can't hear what he's saying. I just remembered these little moments like that. And we just were having our own scene back there. I love those. We're always acting. You never know what the camera's getting. You never know. Well, now we go to Jim's interview. He's a shoe in. David Wallace is like falling all over him. Yeah. I mean, David Wallace should have started the interview by saying you're hired. David Wallace should have started the interview by saying, Will you be my best friend?
安吉拉和布莱恩即兴发挥了这一点。他说，等等，他得到这份工作了吗？我只是摇了摇头。我说，没有。你听不到他在说什么。我只是记得那些小瞬间。我们在后面演我们自己的戏。我喜欢那些。我们一直在演戏。你永远不知道摄像机在拍什么。你永远不知道。好吧，现在我们去吉姆的面试。他是稳操胜券。大卫·华莱士简直对他爱不释手。是的。我的意思是，大卫·华莱士应该在面试开始时就说你被录用了。大卫·华莱士应该在面试开始时就说，你愿意做我最好的朋友吗？
It's so true. Everybody wants Jim to be their best friend. He's a very likable guy. Yeah. He's a great guy. Yeah. So David's asking him a few questions. And he says, what is your favorite thing?
这太真实了。每个人都想让吉姆成为他们最好的朋友。他是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。是的。他是个很棒的人。是的。所以大卫问了他几个问题。他说，你最喜欢的东西是什么？
What do you like most about the Scranton office? And it's right at this moment that Jim opens up his little folder. And there is like a note of encouragement from Pam, along with a little yogurt lid that she has saved since Office Olympics. You know what that note says to me? What? I would have waited for you until after your interview. I wouldn't have gone and met my friends for a boozy lunch somewhere. Exactly.
你最喜欢斯克兰顿办公室的哪一点？就在这一刻，吉姆打开了他的小文件夹。里面有一张帕姆写的鼓励字条，还有她在“办公室奥运会”后一直保存着的一个酸奶盖。你知道那张字条对我说了什么吗？什么？我会等你面试结束后再走。我不会去和朋友们吃什么酒肉午餐。没错。
Thank you, Angela. Thank you. You matter. happens to you matters to me. Yeah. And Jim looks at that and he says his favorite thing about the Scranton office were the friendships. And that's when David asks him, where do you see yourself in 10 years? Well, Jim is rattled now. He had all these answers ready to go. I'm sure he had prepared for this interview. But now Pam is there with him. Yeah. And we flash back to the beach. And we hear Jim tells Pam why he left Scranton.
谢谢你，安吉拉。谢谢。你很重要。发生在你身上的事对我来说很重要。是的。吉姆看着那个，他说他最喜欢斯克兰顿办公室的地方就是友谊。就在那时，大卫问他，你十年后会是什么样子？好吧，吉姆现在心慌了。他准备好了所有答案。我敢肯定他为这次面试做了准备。但现在帕姆和他在一起。是的。我们闪回到海滩。我们听到吉姆告诉帕姆他为什么离开斯克兰顿。
He acknowledges he's never really come back. And then Pam, talk about some Pam sass. I thought this was super ballsy. She's like, well, I wish you would. Whoa! Yeah, well, now we sort of hear Jim's interview. We hear like he's distracted, he's making jokes. We cut to a Pam talk.
他承认他从未真正回来过。然后帕姆，谈谈帕姆的傲娇。我觉得这超级大胆。她说，好吧，我希望你能回来。哇！是的，现在我们听到了吉姆的面试。我们听到他心不在焉，他在开玩笑。我们切到一个帕姆的访谈。
talking head, where she explains, she hasn't really heard anything, Jim probably got the job, you know, there's no reason for him not to get the job. And she's, she's really like, you can see her trying to process it and stay really positive. She's, all day, she's been trying to stay really positive about this and convincing herself that her and Jim are friends. This is in the past. The beach closure. That was closure. And, you know, she says, we just never got the timing right. And that's okay. And then Jim walks in the room. I mean, she's so surprised to see him. Yeah, he interrupts the talking head and asks her if she wants to have dinner. She says, yeah. And then he's like, it's a date. Jenna, many, many people have talked about how great you are in that moment. And you are.
访谈中，她解释说她没听到什么消息，吉姆可能得到了这份工作，你知道，他没有理由得不到这份工作。她，她真的，你可以看出她在努力消化这件事并保持非常积极的态度。她，整天，她都在努力对此保持积极态度，并说服自己她和吉姆是朋友。这是过去的事了。海滩闭幕。那是结束。而且，你知道，她说，我们只是从未把握好时机。没关系。然后吉姆走进房间。我是说，她看到他非常惊讶。是的，他打断了访谈，问她是否想一起吃晚饭。她说，好。然后他说，这是一次约会。珍娜，很多人都谈到你在那一刻表现得有多棒。你确实很棒。
You are. You are so good in that moment. So many emotions go across your face and your eyes tear up. Ken Quapas said you made him cry. Well, here's the thing. I owe that moment to Ken Quapis. And I'll tell you why. A lot of people wrote in and wanted to know what was going through my head during that scene when Jim finally asked Pam out. it's crazy because Ken Quapis, he was a type of father figure to us, right? Angela, when he was on the podcast, he explained that his technique is to love people into their best work. He's just a very gentle, kind soul. He's so, so kind. I'm going to cry just thinking about it. I think, and I don't know, but I think we got that on the first take. I think what you are watching is the first take.
你是。那一刻你表现得太好了。你的脸上闪过无数种情绪，你的眼睛里噙满了泪水。肯·夸帕斯说你让他哭了。好吧，事情是这样的。我把那一刻归功于肯·夸帕斯。我告诉你为什么。很多人写信想知道当吉姆最终约帕姆出去时，我脑子里在想什么。这很疯狂，因为肯·夸帕斯，他就像我们的父亲一样，对吧？安吉拉，当他参加播客时，他解释说他的技巧是用爱引导人们发挥出最好的工作状态。他是一个非常温柔、善良的灵魂。他太善良了。想到这里我就要哭了。我想，我不知道，但我认为我们是一次拍成的。我想你看到的就是第一遍拍摄。
Oh, wow. Because we had kind of planned it out with the camera when it was going to swish over and when it was going to come back to me. So in that moment when the camera swishes back to me, I was actually looking at Ken Quappas and he had tears in his eyes. And that made me tear up. And we just shared this moment, this private moment of acknowledgement for this journey of this character. and he smiled at me in a way that a parent smiles at you when they're proud of you? Listen, if Ken Kwapas looked at me with tears in his eyes smiling, I would disintegrate because he's just, it's like your dad looking at you like that.
哦，哇。因为我们已经和摄像机计划好了什么时候切换过来，什么时候切回我。所以当摄像机切回我时，我实际上是在看着肯·夸帕斯，他眼里含着泪水。这让我流泪了。我们分享了这一刻，这一刻是对这个角色旅程的私人认可。他看着我的微笑方式，就像父母为你感到骄傲时那样？听着，如果肯·夸帕斯眼里含着泪水微笑着看着我，我会崩溃的，因为他就像你的父亲那样看着你。
Yes. Like you did it, kiddo. You did it. Yes. Yes. And I don't even know if that performance could have been there with any other director. Oh, I don't think so. I mean, as much as...
是的。就像你做到了，孩子。你做到了。是的。是的。我甚至不知道如果没有其他导演，那种表演是否还能达到那种效果。哦，我不这么认为。我是说，尽管……
That was a moment between Ken and I. That was about so much about my personal Jenna journey with Ken Quappas on this show. From the very first day. Yeah. Well, it was a beautiful, beautiful moment. And I have one question for you and all the fans out there. What? Did Jim freaking leave Karen in New York?
那是肯和我之间的一刻。那关于我在这个节目中与肯·夸帕斯的个人旅程。从第一天开始。是的。好吧，那是一个美丽、美丽的时刻。我有一个问题要问你和所有的粉丝。什么？吉姆那个混蛋把凯伦留在纽约了吗？
They rode together. He drove back alone. What the F? Well, I'll tell you. So, first of all, there were actually two versions in the script for the ending of this episode. There was this version with Jim interrupting my talking head. And then there was a second version, which we shot. And in the script, it says, shoot both versions.
他们一起去的。他独自开车回来。搞什么鬼？好吧，我告诉你。首先，剧本里其实有两个版本的结局。有一个版本是吉姆打断了我的访谈。然后是第二个版本，我们拍了。在剧本里，写着，两个版本都拍。
It's not in the deleted scenes. What is it? Okay, it's not in the deleted scenes, but we shot it. So in the second version, you hear voiceover of Jim throwing his interview with David but it's even more it's like he's really cracking jokes
它不在删除的片段里。那是什么？好吧，它不在删除的片段里，但我们拍了。所以在第二个版本中，你听到吉姆在面试中故意搞砸的画外音，但更夸张的是，他真的在开玩笑
he's not taking it seriously at all to the point that David actually says do you even want this job oh that would have made me uncomfortable yeah it really tips it a little bit more than what you see meanwhile while all that's happening you see Pam leaving for the day
他根本没把它当回事，以至于大卫实际上问他，你真的想要这份工作吗？哦，那会让我感到不舒服。是的，它确实比你看到的版本更过分。与此同时，当这一切发生时，你看到帕姆下班离开
she doesn't do a talking head she's just leaving for the day She gets in the elevator. She goes down the elevator. And then when the elevator doors open, Jim is standing there. And she says, you're back. And he says, yeah, do you want to go to dinner? And Pam says, yeah, I do.
她没有做访谈，她只是下班离开。她进了电梯。她下了电梯。然后当电梯门打开时，吉姆站在那里。她说，你回来了。他说，是的，你想去吃晚饭吗？帕姆说，是的，我想。
And she walks out of the elevator and Jim pushes the camera back into the elevator. And as the doors are closing, they walk off together and he puts his arm around her. and they smile at each other. Oh, no, no, no, no, no. I don't like it. I don't like it. I like the way it is. Well, I touched base with Dave Rogers, who said that that scene exists.
她走出电梯，吉姆把摄像机推回电梯。当门关上时，他们一起走开了，他搂住了她。他们互相微笑。哦，不，不，不，不，不。我不喜欢。我不喜欢。我喜欢现在的版本。好吧，我联系了戴夫·罗杰斯，他说那个场景确实存在。
That alternate. He's like, I have that in an archive. He's like, I think we should throw that up sometime. You could see it if you want. But he also said that it was never, ever part of the cut of the show. They always had the one in that you see now, and then they would play the alternate for people. Everyone voted for what you see, but they also shot in New York an ending where you see Karen crying because Jim broke up with her. And I'm sure Dave Rogers has that.
那个替代版本。他说，我把它存档了。他说，我想我们应该找个时间放出来。如果你想看的话可以看到。但他还说，它从来没有被剪进节目里。他们总是保留你现在看到的那个版本，然后他们会给人们播放替代版本。每个人都投票选择了你看到的那个，但他们还在纽约拍了一个结局，你看到凯伦在哭，因为吉姆和她分手了。我相信戴夫·罗杰斯有那个片段。
I picture Dave Rogers having this hard drive in a vault and it's like Mission Impossible. It's like ding ding ding ding ding with all these codes and traps because he is holding on. to some serious office footage. Well, listen, now we find out who does get the job. We know it's not Jim. We know it's not Michael. We're assuming it's Karen. But guess what?
我想象戴夫·罗杰斯把这个硬盘锁在保险库里，就像《碟中谍》一样。就像叮叮叮叮叮，带着所有这些密码和陷阱，因为他保留着一些严肃的办公室素材。好吧，听着，现在我们发现是谁得到了这份工作。我们知道不是吉姆。我们知道不是迈克尔。我们假设是凯伦。但你猜怎么着？
Someone else interviewed, and they had an MBA. Yes, an unknown MBA. Masters of Business Administration. Is that right? Don't know. Not sure. Masters of Business, something with an A. Guys, it's Ryan.
还有其他人面试，他们有工商管理硕士学位。是的，一个未知的工商管理硕士。是这样吗？不知道。不确定。工商管理硕士，带个A的什么。伙计们，是瑞安。
Ryan the temp will not be getting your coffee anymore. He's going to corporate. Well, we talked about this last week with Paul because a lot of people wanted to know, why does Ryan get the job? And you know, lady, Dave Rogers told me they did shoot an alternate scene where Karen gets the job. Where she's crying in New York and then the phone rings. And they offer her the job. So I just think it's very, very interesting how they left options on the table for this big finale.
临时工瑞安不会再给你倒咖啡了。他要去总部了。好吧，我们上周和保罗谈过这个，因为很多人想知道，为什么瑞安得到了这份工作？而且，女士，戴夫·罗杰斯告诉我他们确实拍了一个替代场景，凯伦得到了这份工作。她在纽约哭，然后电话响了。他们给了她这份工作。所以我认为他们为这个大结局留有余地是非常非常有趣的。
I think maybe in some cases they were still debating who gets the job. How do Jim and Pam get together? Well, yeah, it seems like they wanted to give themselves some choices. But we also know what was going on at this time, which is that Rashida booked her role on Parks and Rec. And she was going to be starting that job. So, A, they needed, you know, finally Jim and Pam to be together without any kind of distraction. And also, Rashida just got a great new job. Yeah, so she can't be Michael's boss at corporate.
我想也许在某些情况下，他们还在争论谁得到这份工作。吉姆和帕姆是怎么在一起的？好吧，是的，看起来他们想给自己一些选择。但我们也知道当时发生了什么，那就是拉什达预订了她在《公园与游憩》中的角色。她要开始那份工作了。所以，A，他们需要，你知道，最终让吉姆和帕姆在一起，没有任何干扰。而且，拉什达刚刚得到了一份很棒的新工作。是的，所以她不能在总部做迈克尔的老板。
No, no, she's going to be over at Parks and Rec. And I think there were a lot of story endings that had wrap-ups that didn't make it to air because it was such a big episode. One of them I loved was there's a scene where Jan is moving in. It's moving in day. there's a moving truck, there's like guys, and she's barking orders at them in front of the condo, and Michael's just watching it all in horror. He's like, oh, crap, what have I done? And it's such a good scene. Oh my gosh. They had to rent that location and shoot that scene, and then it didn't even make it in the episode. Yeah, I know, I know, but boy, is it going to set up some good stuff like
不，不，她要去《公园与游憩》了。我想有很多故事结局因为这是一个大剧集而没有播出。我喜欢的一个场景是简搬进来的场景。那是搬家日。有一辆搬家卡车，有几个家伙，她在公寓前对他们大喊大叫，迈克尔只是惊恐地看着这一切。他想，哦，该死，我做了什么？这是一个非常好的场景。天哪。他们不得不租下那个地点并拍摄那个场景，结果它甚至没有出现在剧集中。是的，我知道，我知道，但天哪，它会为一些好的情节做铺垫，比如
dinner party. Oh, yes, dinner party. I am so excited for that episode. I'm so excited for season four. I just watched the dinner party bloopers and it got me so excited because we laughed our butts off. Oh, I can't wait to talk about it. Well, guys, this rounds out season three and we will see you soon with season four. Ampat. That's four in Indonesian. Katra. That's four in French. That's four in French. Do you want me to say four in Spanish? Sure. Quattro, ampat, quattro, catra. Did I say it right in French?
晚宴。哦，是的，晚宴。我太期待那一集了。我太期待第四季了。我刚看了晚宴的NG片段，这让我非常兴奋，因为我们笑得前仰后合。哦，我迫不及待想谈谈它了。好吧，伙计们，这结束了第三季，我们很快会在第四季见到你们。Ampat。那是印尼语的四。Katra。那是法语的四。那是法语的四。你想让我用西班牙语说四吗？当然。Quattro, ampat, quattro, catra。我法语说对了吗？
You did. I.V. That's four in Roman numerals. See you in Susan Ampat. Bye, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
你说对了。I.V. 那是罗马数字的四。Susan Ampat见。再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. We want to talk to you guys a little bit about new ego protein waffles. It's really good, taste great, plus it's going to give you 20% of your daily protein. Yes, eggo protein plus waffles provide the same great taste of ego that you know and love, plus 10 grams of protein per serving. I made the new eggo protein waffles for my kids the other day.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。我们想和你们谈谈新的Eggo蛋白华夫饼。它真的很好，味道很棒，而且它会为你提供每日蛋白质需求的20%。是的，Eggo蛋白加华夫饼提供了你所知道和喜爱的Eggo的同样美味，每份含有10克蛋白质。前几天我为我的孩子们做了新的Eggo蛋白华夫饼。
They didn't even know that they were protein waffles. They're just the eggo waffles that you know and love. I know they have protein. They're just yummy waffles. Yes. I mean, listen, I know we're talking about breakfast, but I have shared this before. I like them as an afternoon treat. And when your teenagers come home hungry, guess what's real easy to give them?
他们甚至不知道那是蛋白华夫饼。它们只是你所知道和喜爱的Eggo华夫饼。我知道它们有蛋白质。它们只是美味的华夫饼。是的。我是说，听着，我知道我们在谈论早餐，但我之前分享过。我喜欢把它们当作下午的点心。当你的青少年饿着肚子回家时，猜猜给他们什么最容易？
A little protein waffle. They say you can fuel your morning, but you can also fuel your afternoon. Sure can. Head to your local grocery store to fuel your morning with ego protein waffles and pancakes available at retailers nationwide. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个小蛋白华夫饼。他们说你可以为你的早晨补充能量，但你也可以为你的下午补充能量。当然可以。前往你当地的杂货店，用全国零售商处有售的Eggo蛋白华夫饼和煎饼为你的早晨补充能量。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。